et professeur également à l'École
polytechnique ce prix partagé avec deux
et Sonia et
j'allais dire francilien mais bon chacun
son
prix partagé avec deux collègues
chercheurs américains et autrichiens
récompense leur travaux novateurs en
physique quantique qualifiés de seconde
révolution quantique cette récompense
est une immense fierté pour la recherche
française et une nouvelle preuve de sa
très grande qualité et nous avons bien
entendu chacun notre place la
responsabilité de veiller à garder des
talents de cet envergure dans notre pays
et en faire éclore de nouveau je donnais
à saluer le travail de cette éminent
chercheur alors que nous vous
auditionnons ce matin monsieur le
Président un mois après la rentrée
universitaire il me semblait important
que notre Commission puisse échanger
avec le président de France université
nouvelle dénomination de la Conférence
des présidents d'université association
qui nous le savons fédère les dirigeants
exécutifs des universités et des
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
monsieur le Président c'est la première
fois que vous vous exprimez devant nous
en tout cas en commission puisque bien
sûr vous avez été déjà auditionné par
les rapporteurs je vous souhaite donc la
bienvenue vous êtes professeur de
pneumologie et vous avez dirigé
l'Université de Bordeaux
de 2014 à 2022 et vous avez été élu à la
tête de France université en décembre
la rentrée universitaire de 2022 et la
première de la nouvelle ministre de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche Sylvie retaillou que nous
avons reçu en juillet dernier les
dossiers qu'elle a traité ne manquent
pas je mentionnerai les principaux sur
lequel nous sommes intéressés d'avoir
votre analyse en vue notamment de
l'examen du projet de loi de finance de
2023 s'agissant des établissements cette
entrée est évidemment marquée par
l'envoler des prix de l'énergie une
polémique aînée de la décision de
l'Université de Strasbourg de fermer ses
portes deux semaines supplémentaires
faire cet hiver pour faire face à la
crise énergétique la ministre a réagi en
affirmant que si tous les établissements
d'enseignement supérieur devaient
réfléchir à un plan de sobriété il ne
fallait surtout pas que cela se fasse
aux dépens des étudiants comment
conciliez-vous
comment voyez-vous pardon la
conciliation entre ces deux objectifs
comptez-vous sur une compensation de
l'État à ce stade rien ne semble prévu
dans les crédits du prochain PLF ceci
m'amène à la question des moyens sur
lequel je ne doute pas notre rapporteur
reviendra également l'ambition de la
ministre est de privilégier une
planification plus réelle pour donner
plus de visibilité aux établissements
cette démarche doit se traduire dès 2023
par la signature des premiers
contrats pluriannuels d'objectifs et de
moyens destinés à responsabilité de
responsabiliser davantage tous les
acteurs ce nouvel outil contractuel
est-il selon vous de nature à renforcer
l'autonomie des universités doit-il
s'appliquer à toute quel que soit leur
taille j'en viens maintenant aux
étudiants la ministre entend mettre
l'accent sur le premier cycle en
travaillant notamment avec son collègue
de l'éducation nationale sur le
continuum bac -3 Bac +3 cher à notre
commission
quelle voie d'amélioration
identique
identifiez-vous sur ce sujet
la ministre a également annoncé il y a
quelques semaines l'ouverture en 2023 du
nouvelle plateforme numérique qui doit
faciliter l'affectation des étudiants en
master avec pour objectif de résorber
les tensions entre l'offre et la demande
à l'université à ce stade de leur étude
qu'en attendez-vous enfin une
concertation sur la vie étudiante doit
débuter ce mois-ci avec les acteurs des
territoires les établissements et les
étudiants pour traiter des sujets aussi
cruciaux que les bourses la santé
mentale le logement la restauration
l'accès au sport et à la culture comment
abordez-vous cet exercice monsieur le
Président vous je vais vous donner la
parole pour une intervention liminaire
d'une dizaine de minutes et à l'issue de
celle-ci vous serez interrogé d'abord
par nos rapporteurs Stéphane piennoir et
Laure Darko et puis ensuite bien sûr
chacun des sénatrices et sénateurs
présents pourront s'exprimer pour que
l'échange soit le
le plus vivant est direct possible je
vous donne la parole monsieur le
président
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
chers Laurent Lafont Madame et Monsieur
les rapporteurs chers
Stéphane piennois mesdames les
sénatrices et les sénateurs je vous
remercie très sincèrement à
chaleureusement pour votre invitation
parce que c'est en réalité un honneur de
m'exprimer devant vous pour la première
fois et c'est l'occasion de dire notre
reconnaissance à la commission parce
qu'elle a je pense clairement nourri
enrichi le débat sur l'université
notamment à travers
l'expertise et le travail de différents
rapporteurs que je salue ici avec qui on
travaille toujours en très bonne
intelligence vous l'avez dit France
université à travers ses responsables de
de 120 établissements 73 universités ça
représente près de 2 millions
d'étudiants de cent mille personnes
ça doit représenter parmi eux 55 000
enseignants chercheurs et puis ce qu'on
oublie parfois 3000 laboratoires de
recherche publique nous verrons que
Allonnes des questions d'énergie ça
n'est pas un détail elle concentre donc
la plus grande partie des forces de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
du pays et j'aimerais effectivement
puisque vous m'en donnez l'opportunité
aborder trois sujets avec vous avant de
répondre à vos questions le premier
c'est effectivement de faire un point
sur la rentrée universitaire le deuxième
c'est le budget vous l'avez évoqué
monsieur le Président et puis peut-être
évoquer si j'en ai le temps quelques
enjeux à venir de ce nouveau quinquennat
puis avant tout comme vous saisir cette
opportunité de féliciter à l'un aspect
c'est
professeur
université paris-saclet à l'Institut
d'Optique Institut Polytechnique prix
Nobel de physique
qui doit nous
faire souligner le fait que le le combat
de France université et bien de garder
la France au rang des grands pays
scientifiques alors regardez les talents
mais essayez de maintenir les conditions
ou de les développer qui ont permis à
ses collègues de devenir
prix Nobel et ça c'est une préoccupation
de France université alors rapidement un
point d'État sur la rentrée
universitaire bon nous sommes très
heureux de de cette année qui débute
sans le spectre de fermeture du covid ou
la pandémie les étudiants sont dans nos
murs
cette année nous accueillons sur les 73
universités plus d'un million 700000
étudiants dans les cursus LMD je ne peux
pas ne pas rappeler ici que en 10 ans
les universités ont vu leur effectif
étudiant s'accroître de près de 20% et
que cette augmentation de la démographie
même si elle est moins élevée dans les
années à venir elle va se poursuivre
sans compter les objectifs que se fixe
le pays en termes d'accueil des
étudiants étrangers et le pays n'a pas
suffisamment anticipé cette croissance
alors que l'université française est
comme dans toute les démocraties une
pierre angulaire de l'éducation et du
développement économique et social
la formation qu'on y délivre est adossé
à la recherche dès le premier cycle
c'est essentiel pour développer l'esprit
critique la rigueur résoudre les
problèmes complexes
que l'on connaît aujourd'hui à l'aune
des crises et des défis mondiaux et
l'université française c'est beaucoup
transformé elle s'est rapprochée du
monde professionnel
je crois qu'il faut garder en tête que
les formations aujourd'hui préparent
désormais au métier de demain
en lien bien sûr avec les transitions et
de plus en plus de manière de plus en
plus adaptée à l'ancrage et aux besoins
des territoires et ça c'est c'est le
fruit d'une transformation récente qu'il
faut souligner bien sûr cette prophétie
signalisation doit être accélérée cela a
été souhaité par par la ministre alors
donc l'accès à l'université est
importante c'est bien sûr accès à
l'université aujourd'hui veut dire
évoquer parcoursup cette année on a eu
000 candidats donc 600620
000 étudiants lycéens pardon mais vous
savez que vous avez aussi les étudiants
il y a 86000 étudiants en réorientation
et 95
000 étudiants en reprise d'études
près de 90% ont reçu une proposition en
87% pour les lycéens ça montre à 93
alors pour nous
un parcoursup et souvent critiqué pour
nous c'est un défi un outil efficace de
l'accès à l'enseignement supérieur c'est
quelque chose qui fonctionne c'est une
plateforme
d'affectation d'informations qui prend
en compte en moyenne 12 millions de vœux
de la part des uns et des autres mais
comme cela a été rappelé par la ministre
elle-même peut-être ici devant vous
c'est quelque chose qui doit continuer à
évoluer c'est quelque chose qui doit
être évalué et dont il faut penser que
l'intervention humaine y est
omniprésente parce que parcoursup c'est
pas un grand algorithme qui par lui-même
affecte des places pour les lycéens
c'est les commissions d'examen en amont
qui sont des commissions pédagogiques
c'est le travail des professeurs dans
les lycées c'est les équipes dans le
rectorat et c'est souvent aussi un
troisième tour qu'on oublie qui est
catalogue une fois que parcoursup est
fini entre les établissements et les
rectorats pour affecter les derniers
lycéens alors je veux ici peut-être
saluer parce que c'est un trait
important le choix de 200000 candidats
qui sont allés vers l'apprentissage
l'apprentissage est une voix qui permet
à la fois
d'accentuer la démocratisation de
l'enseignement supérieur
vous avez
un taux d'insertion professionnelle qui
est 4 à 5 fois supérieur aux formations
sans alternance et puis permet de
continuer à rapprocher université
entreprise
il convient de garantir ce type de
formation et cela n'empêche pas d'être
vigilant sur les éventuels effets
d'aubaine que l'on peut dénoncer
vis-à-vis de certaines formations qui ne
sont pas universitaires
l'autre point de la rentrée monsieur le
Président vous l'avez évoqué aussi c'est
celui de la sobriété évidemment comme
tous les opérateurs de l'État cela vous
surprend pas c'est un défi collectif
pour cette rentrée
je crois que le gouvernement va
présenter son plan général et les les
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
seront en train de peaufiner le leur je
pense que les universités comme au monde
la crise covid elle prenne leur
responsabilité elles vont faire cet
effort et elle ont la volonté
d'atteindre et je pense qu'elles peuvent
atteindre facilement les 10% de baisse
de consommation d'ici 2024 ce sera
peut-être une autre affaire que de
diminuer à 40% d'ici 2030 mais on a
souvent confondu dans les débats à ces
derniers jours
la baisse de consommation le plan de
sobriété et les questions de surcoût
[Musique]
à la baisse de la sobriété et la baisse
de la consommation suppose des
changements de structure des changements
dans les usages dans les usages le
surcoût c'est une question à laquelle
nous sommes immédiatement confrontés
dans le contexte du plan de loi de
finance alors s'agissant des structures
peut-être un mot pour rappeler qu'il
faut
anticiper ces interventions lourdes sur
le bâti avec une trajectoire de de de
réduction des consommations on dit
souvent juste titre que nous avons des
passoires énergétiques il faut faire un
recensement avoir des indicateurs de
consommation il faut le faire assez vite
les enjeux sont assez différents d'une
université à l'autre en fonction de
l'état de son bâti de son âge de son
étendu
et puis concernant les usages
nous pour France université et je le
redis puisque vous avez abordé cette
question nous n'est pas question de
reporter la charge du collectif sur les
étudiants les personnels et les familles
et donc pour les présidents à la
majorité des présidents il n'est pas
question de remettre les étudiants en
enseignement à distance comme cela avait
été fait pendant la pandémie il s'agit
pas de faire face à une crise passagère
il faut inscrire une démarche qui est
une démarche des co-responsabilités dans
la durée et qui suppose d'accompagner de
nouveaux comportements mais pas de de
pénaliser et de dégrader le niveau de
formation qui est aujourd'hui proposé
permettez-moi cependant de vous rappeler
et nous y reviendrons peut-être avec le
budget que sans votre aide et celui de
l'État il sera difficile d'atteindre les
40% en 2030
et nous avons besoin vraiment d'une
démarche collective
alors quelques éléments de satisfaction
et de perspective de rentrer toujours
bon le retour des étudiants étrangers
000 en 2020-2021 France université avait
proposé en début d'année de faire de
notre pays le premier pays d'accueil des
étudiants en France c'est pour des
étudiants étrangers pour l'Union
européenne je pense que c'est un enjeu
majeur d'ici la fin du quinquennat
satisfaction aussi concernant le
lancement par la ministre Sylvie
Retailleau de la réforme des bourses que
nous souhaitons de longues dates
alors si France université avait salué
au début de l'été les mesures
d'accompagnement des étudiants je crois
qu'il faut qu'on s'attaque à son système
dans son ensemble et nous pensons qu'il
faut une réforme structurelle des
bourses et de l'accompagnement de la vie
étudiante au niveau territorial et je
pense que on doit saisir cette
opportunité des aujourd'hui
quelques perspectives je sais Monsieur
le Président que cela intéresse la
commission c'est les enjeux liés à
l'éducation nous souhaitons absolument
consolider les liens qui unissent
l'école la société nous pensons que le
rôle de l'université est important le
président de la République a lancé à la
rentrée avec les recteurs des
orientations de la formation des
professeurs de premier degré pour nous
on le dit très clairement il est pas
question de soutenir une réforme qui
sortirait la formation des professeurs
des écoles de l'université nous pensons
que on a besoin de l'information par la
recherche nous pensons que la double
dimension scientifique et
professionnalisante et notre
savoir-faire je suis médecin j'ai été
formé dans une double
dans une double formation
professionnelle à l'hôpital et
scientifiques à l'université il n'y a
aucune raison qu'on ne sache pas ça
qu'on ne sache pas faire ça pour ceux
qui forment les les classes les plus
jeunes alors un mot sur le budget
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs sans entrer dans
le détail du plan de loi de finance 2023
et au-delà des enjeux que l'université
et France université à l'habitude de
vous soumettre je reviens pas sur les
questions de ma salariale de glissement
vieillesse technicité ou de la dépense
de l'État par étudiant
je pense que les universités françaises
ont aujourd'hui une forte inquiétude sur
le financement de l'enseignement
supérieur
on se réjouit de la compensation du
point d'indice en 2023 qui apparaît dans
le plan de loi de finances mais il est
important aujourd'hui de dire d'abord
que le
l'indice pour 2022 n'est pas compensé
c'est à peu près 250 millions d'euros
donc à la charge directe des
établissements
je redis ici que les personnels des
universités sont des fonctionnaires
d'État
les universités autonomes et ne
bénéficient pas de façon systématique et
automatique des revalorisations qui sont
prévues pour les fonctionnaires et cette
situation est unique en France même
parfois si on fait la comparaison avec
les collectivités ça n'est pas la même
chose que les collectivités donc ça
c'est un sujet qui est toujours
d'actualité et de surcroît vous le savez
les universités subissent
au moins autant que les autres
institutions ou les industries les
effets directs de la crise énergétique
nous avons estimé à peu près entre 100
et 120 millions d'euros en fonction avec
les organismes et c'est à peu près 100
millions d'euros rien que pour les
établissements le surcoût de l'énergie
en 2022
ça c'est un montant qui ne sera pas
compensé
dans le
aujourd'hui enfin qui est pas prévu mais
donc pour lesquels les universités
devraient prélever dans leur fondement
avec près de un argent que parfois elles
n'auront pas parce que la situation de
ces universités sont extrêmement
variables et pour l'heure il n'est pas
non plus prévu dans le projet de loi de
finance 2023 qui ne compensation
énergétique pour 2023 qui risque d'être
multiplié par quatre ou cinq et je pense
qu'il est ici monsieur le Président
important de vous rappeler que
l'université c'est 18 millions de mètres
carrés
c'est 20% de l'immobilier de l'État
c'est une très grande partie de d'un
état immobilier qui est qualifié de
passoire énergétique et c'est en même
temps une opportunité pour l'État
d'appréhender les questions de sobriété
et de transition énergétique
je rappelle également que l'université
bien sûr c'est l'accueil des étudiants
on peut discuter de la polémique liée à
l'université Strasbourg mais c'est aussi
l'hébergement de la quasi-totalité de la
recherche publique les laboratoires
qu'il s'agissent
d'ailleurs le surcoût sur les organismes
ça va être 8 9 millions pour l'INRA et
ça va être 2 millions pour l'imcer mais
je vous l'ai dit c'est 100 millions pour
les universités donc beaucoup
d'équipements sont branchés en
permanence les instruments de mesure en
physique les ventilation l'entretien des
lignes et cellulaires les
supercalculateurs on a beaucoup
d'exemples qui sont des infrastructures
qui prennent une part prépondérante dans
la dépense d'énergie mais qui sont aussi
fondamentales pour le fonctionnement de
la recherche et donc du pays
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire a récemment
promis de trouver des moyens pour
compenser les surcoûts à juste titre
indiquer que la France n'est pas une
puissance de 5e ordre je je vous
confirme que nous ne pouvons pas nous
permettre que ce surcoût affecte les
étudiants et la recherche publique
je sais que notre ministre Sylvie
retaillot qui connaît bien la question
travail pour trouver des solutions mais
nous devons collectivement avec les
parlementaires avec vous
essayez de contribuer à traiter ce sujet
en tout cas France université est très
sensible à l'aide que vous pourrez
apporter à ce dossier et dernier point
extrêmement rapide parce que
on pourrait le prolonger et c'est pas
l'objet mais
on a quelques enjeux dans le nouveau
quinquennat la LPR d'abord les
universités sont vous le savez le
premier opérateur de recherche en France
on doit apporter des réponses aux enjeux
actuels qui sont des enjeux majeurs on
était très favorable à la loi de
programmation de la recherche
nous en avons discuté ici avec certains
d'entre vous
attention cependant que la période de 10
ans était trop longue donc on pense
qu'il faut concentrer l'effort sur au
moins 7 ans on va pas arriver aux 3%
alors on va pas débattre de la
contribution de la crise pardon mais je
pense qu'il faut peut-être saisir
l'opportunité de la clause de revoyure
prévue en 2023 pour raccourcir cette
durée initiale il est essentiel nous
avons introduit tous les deux
cette séance en félicitant alain Aspect
notre prix Nobel il faut massivement
investir dans la recherche fondamentale
c'est de là que viennent les progrès
techniques et c'est de là que vient
l'innovation on a eu aussi l'occasion
d'en parler ici avec certains d'entre
vous et je salue le rapport qui a été
fait ce sont les viviers de recherche
fondamentale qui font l'innovation des
pays il n'y a pas d'innovation qui soit
commandée prescrites sur tel objet ce
sont ces écosystèmes que la France
en partie mais qu'elle devrait continuer
à construire sur les transitions ensuite
c'est très important nous repensons les
formations pour adapter les métiers de
demain on ne part pas de rien vous savez
que les l'acquisition aux étudiants des
par les étudiants des compétences
techniques et scientifiques
autant que ce qu'on appelle en bon
français les soft skills c'est quelque
chose qui est maintenant intégré y
compris dans les premiers cycles nous
avons des transitions écologiques mais
aussi sociétales que pour lesquelles la
jeunesse nous oblige à une forme
d'exemplarité aujourd'hui vous avez vu
l'expression des étudiants dans des très
grandes écoles c'est pareil à
l'université je pense que ça change un
tout petit peu la façon de voir les
choses y compris pour mes collègues
présidentes et président du université
et puis nous avons d'autres enjeux qui
sont très importants qui pourraient être
évoqués comme l'organisation de la
recherche la formation
et le futur de la recherche dans le
domaine de la santé qui nous préoccupe
et qui feront peut-être l'objet de
questions je vous remercie en tout cas
pour votre attention alors je sais pas
monsieur le Président si j'ai répondu à
certaines de vos questions sur la
fermeture sur la compensation sur les
contrats d'objectifs et
moyens
je peux répondre aux questions à ces
questions-là en fonction de la question
des autres sénatrice et sénateurs je ne
doute pas que vous en aurez là-dessus et
puis sur un certain nombre de points sur
lequel vous êtes déjà intervenus dans
votre propos liminaire en tout cas je
suis sûr que sur la question de
raccourcissement de des délais de la
durée de la LPR et vous ne vous prêchez
des convaincus ici donc il y aura pas
beaucoup de débats là-dessus
alors je vais donner dans un premier
temps la parole à nos deux rapporteurs
Stéphane piénoir lors d'Arcos qui vont
vous poser une série de questions vous y
répondrez et puis après les autres
sénateurs et sénatrices pourront
intervenir je ne sais pas entre Stéphane
et Laure qui commence
merci chers collègues merci monsieur le
Président d'abord de votre venue c'est
la première fois effectivement d'une
audition en plénière on a eu l'occasion
évidemment de se rencontrer à de
nombreuses reprises notamment pour ce
retour sur la LPR mais je laisserai l'or
s'exprimer à ce à ce sujet merci pour
votre propos liminaire avec vous avez
balayé un certain nombre de sujets qui
font l'actualité et qui nous intéresse
au premier plan sur le finalement le
plan de la région de la rentrée pardon
et de la et du budget j'aurais quelques
questions complémentaires sur
sur le budget concernant le la
compensation du point d'indice vous
l'avez dit compensation qui est
envisagée uniquement pour la période de
2000 pour l'année 2023 tout entière ça
laisse béant si je puis dire toute une
période celle de 2022 une demi-année
quand même de qui n'est pas compensé une
enveloppe de 370 millions d'euros a été
prévu pour la cette hausse du point
d'indice sur l'ensemble de l'année 2023
une petite règle de calcul assez simple
nous fait dire qu'il y a un manque à
gagner d'environ la moitié à manque à
gagner en tout cas il manque à compenser
d'environ la moitié pour les universités
est-ce que vous à combien vous chiffrez
exactement cette charge financière pour
les pour les universités pour l'année
2022 sur les prix de l'énergie je ne
doute pas que ce sera au cœur des
questions d'un certain nombre de mes
collègues
là aussi il est prévu de de compenser en
fonction des capacités de trésorerie ce
sont les mots de la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur
je sais que ça ça a fait grincer des
dents et ça a évoqué ça a provoqué
quelques mesures qui ont qui ont suscité
pas mal de réactions le président Lafont
l'a dit tout à l'heure avec la fermeture
envisagée de 15 jours supplémentaires
pour l'Université de Strasbourg on a
bien compris que c'était un c'était un
appel pour
alerter sur la situation des des
universités est-ce que c'est une méthode
qui qui vous convient ne convient de
regarder au cas par cas la situation des
universités pour le dire très clairement
la ministre considère que durant la
période de confinement les universités
ont fait un centre de
d'économie de provision on appelle ça
comme on voudra mais en tout cas c'est
ce fonds de roulement qui devrait
pouvoir permettre de faire face aux
surcoût en tout cas pour pour l'année
2022 vous avez dit que pour l'année 2022
c'était à peu près 100 millions d'euros
le surcoût est-ce que vous avez une
évaluation chiffrée pour l'année 2023 on
connaît on sait évidemment l'instabilité
autour des du prix de l'énergie très
volatile actuellement mais néanmoins ce
que vous avez puisqu'on est dans une
période de budgétaire programmé cette
cette ce surcoût pour l'année 2023
il y a des choses qu'on peut qu'on peut
évidemment vous avez parlé beaucoup de
sobriété des choses qu'on peut
tenter de faire la rénovation thermique
des bâtiments avec 18 millions de mètres
carrés de bâtis c'est évidemment un
souci permanent pour les universités
certaines sont emparés il y a une
inégalité aussi très forte entre les
différents campus la seule chose que ne
peut pas faire un ministre et même un
président de la République c'est
décréter que la température de
l'ébullition de l'eau serait partait de
100 à 80 degrés donc vous l'avez dit sur
les labos il y a des il y a des charges
constantes et permanentes et qu'on ne
peut pas comprimer qu'on ne peut pas
réduire est-ce que vous avez donc ce
plan de sobriété énergétique commence
cette demande a été perçue par les
universités et dans quel délai vous-même
allez faire des propositions en ce sens
où ça que le gouvernement doit proposer
un plan d'ensemble demain me semble-t-il
demain jeudi et deux derniers points
assez rapidement le premier pour
compléter quand même les contrats
d'objectifs et de moyens mais pas tout à
fait répondu au président Lafont sur je
vais le dire comme ça une forme de perte
d'autonomie de la part des des
universités et il y a évidemment des
moyens mais il y a des contreparties
est-ce que alors l'autonomie des
universités évidemment toute relative
puisqu'elle est liée à des dotations des
crédits nationaux mais néanmoins est-ce
que est-ce que vous considérez que c'est
cette méthode est vous convient est-ce
que la contrepartie d'une évaluation a
postériori vous convient également et
puis sur la réforme des bourses
quel levier envisagez-vous vous avez
parlé me semble-t-il de de considération
au niveau territorial c'est un vaste
chantier si est-ce que vous considérez
qu'il faut intégrer des paramètres
territoriaux dans le calcul des bourses
de l'enseignement supérieur
je vais m'arrêter là pour laisser
quelques questions à mes collègues
lors d'Archos merci monsieur le
Président
Monsieur le Président je vous remercie
infiniment excusez-moi mais sûr que
let's juste vous poussez parce que sinon
je ne vois pas le président merci
beaucoup
je vous remercie de ce que vous avez pu
dire sur sur notre rapport avec Stéphane
chinois à la suite de la loi
programmation recherche
et bien évidemment en effet comme le
disait le président Lafont vous savez le
combat que nous avons mené ici au Sénat
pour amener à 7 ans cette programmation
je reviens en effet bien évidemment sur
la LPR
la ministre en tant simplifié la mise en
oeuvre donc de cette LPF pour les
établissements elle a nous a reçu tous
les trois du président Lafont au moment
de la remise notre rapport est-ce que
vous le voyez enfin d'abord quelles sont
les améliorations que vous attendez à
quel échéance vous avez pas la clause de
revoyure que nous attendons tous mais
est-ce que il y a des choses qui
pourraient être améliorées dès
maintenant
maintenant l'organisation du secteur de
la recherche la ministre a déclaré
devant nous vouloir donner un rôle clair
et articulé à chacun avec des politiques
fortes d'université c'est très bien que
pendant la durée de la LPR ça a été une
attente forte de votre côté comment
voyez-vous donc concrètement la
répartition des missions entre les
organismes de recherche et l'université
donc l'essence devrait évoluer le
fonctionnement des UMR
et sachant que le triptyque formation
recherche innovation se joue aussi à
l'échelle européenne vous l'avez dit
comment mieux accompagner nos
universités dans leur politique
d'alliance avec d'autres universités
européennes enfin est-ce que le projet
de loi de finance 2023 tiens ses
promesses même si pour l'instant vous
n'avez pas tous les fléchages s'agissant
du déploiement budgétaire de la LPR si
vous aviez deux minutes aussi pour
revenir du coup sur le préciput puisque
nous étions aussi beaucoup battus à vos
côtés pour une meilleure répartition
merci monsieur le président
le Président je vais vous laisser
répondre de rapporteurs
merci merci pour ces questions
effectivement qui rejoignent les
articule avec la présentation que j'ai
pu en faire alors
peut-être tout d'abord sur les questions
financières budgétaires
monsieur le sénateur pied-noir
sur le point d'indice 2022 nous notre
estimation elle est plutôt de l'ordre de
250 millions d'euros
donc c'est quelque chose qu'on est en
train d'affiner parce que là
l'exécution là du budget 2022 est en
train de se faire donc
elle elle impliquerait effectivement de
faire appel à ce qu'on appelle notre
trésorerie ou le fond de roulement vous
avez évoqué ça
alors un oui il faut le faire au cas par
cas parce que la situation des
universités est extrêmement différente
vous avez des universités qui ont un
tout petit peu un tout petit fond de
roulement alors peut-être qu'il faut
préciser que dans le fond de roulement
vous avez en fait trois composantes vous
avez une composante qui est une forme de
réserve de précaution qui est
de 15 jours de fonctionnement
mais 15 jours même si c'est en
proportion qu'un jour de fonctionnement
d'une petite université ça peut être
quelques centaines de milliers d'euros
universités c'est un million un million
d'eux un million 3 ou plus voilà de Joe
fonctionnement donc vous voyez qu'on se
situe pas dans les dans les mêmes
franges
financière la deuxième composante ce
sont des c'est un argent qui est parfois
fléchés engagé sur des actions qui peut
apparaître dans une trésorerie alors à
force Youri quand on parle d'une
trésorerie si vous examinez la
trésorerie vous allez vous retrouver
avec l'argent du PIA qui est dans la
trésorerie qui est l'argent extra
budgétaire qui lui fait l'objet d'un
emprunt du pays vous n'avez pas payer le
gaz avec l'argent qui a été emprunté et
cet argent est fléché sur des projets
pour le développement de l'université
puis après l'autre composante
c'est
ce qu'une université ou un établissement
peut investir
donc le budget doit être à l'équilibre
lorsqu'il y a une marge qui est faite
elle va dans le fond de roulement et au
bout de plusieurs années vous pouvez à
ce moment-là avoir
ce ces fonds qui vous permettent
d'amorcer des actions et là nous en
avons discuté avec la ministre il faut
faire attention alors je pense que
toutes les universités sont prêtes à
aider et à se remonter les manches parce
qu'il y a un effort national
ce sont des opérateurs de l'État
dans une situation d'exception à
laquelle vous faire face c'est très bien
en revanche il faut réfléchir il faut
être prudent vous avez par exemple un
certain nombre de de
budget de
projets qui ont très
à l'économie même d'énergie parce que
vous allez avoir des investissements
pour
la sobriété pour les panneaux solaires
pour la rénovation etc donc il faut pas
que le serpent en se mordre de la queue
là et que l'on fasse des bêtises et puis
vous avez des projets qui sont des
projets de développement il ne faut pas
que des bons élèves soient punis donc je
pense qu'il faut le faire au cas par cas
mais je pense que c'est compliqué au
regard du surcoût énergétique et vous
parlez du surcoût
monsieur pied-noir effectivement en 2023
on y est pas l'estimé c'est difficile
parce que vous savez les établissements
aussi
tout sont pas passés par la direction de
des achats mais on estime aller de 50 à
500% d'augmentation et donc si on
rapporte ça au surcoût de 100 millions
d'euros ça
ça donne une fourchette en revanche on
est très prudent là-dessus je crois
qu'il faut regarder et donc les
discussions avec la ministre c'est
d'abord
d'avoir un une estimation socle et puis
ensuite de là on est en train de
regarder quels sont les engagements pris
par les établissements en avec leur
prestataire vis-à-vis de l'énergie et
puis de regarder ça avec effectivement
la direction des achats et des
équipements pour voir comment se
projette mais cette estimation est quand
même difficile à faire si elle devait
être de cet ordre là évidemment ça
poserait un problème
c'est un problème que nous partageons
avec les autres acteurs
du pays alors vous parliez de la
perception du plan de sobriété
je pense que les universités le
comprennent mais celles qui sont
peut-être le plus en difficulté et elles
ont une forme d'angoisse
à finaliser un budget ne voudrait pas
qu'il y ait une espèce de fongibilité
entre le fait de devoir assumer un
surcoût de factures énergétique et le
fait d'enseigner ou le fait qu'il est
les conséquences sur l'emploi etc donc
ça
cette perception c'est plutôt cette
cette crainte là
sur les contrats d'objectifs et de
moyens et de performance je crois ce qui
est dit donc il y a un petit pet après
monsieur le Président vous l'avez évoqué
alors oui nous on est favorable un
France université était favorable à ses
contrats et je ne pense pas qu'il aille
à l'encontre de l'autonomie parce que je
pense qu'il va on peut parler pendant
des heures
d'autonomie mais je pense qu'il clarifie
les engagements de part et d'autre c'est
à la condition à la condition qu'il soit
effectivement pluriannuel
et que l'on en change un petit peu
l'évaluation parce que ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est que
vous avez très peu de dialogues
stratégiques et vous avez une dialogue
stratégique qui porte sur une toute
petite partie du budget moi j'étais
président à l'Université de Bordeaux
mondial stratégique porté sur je sais
pas 300 400 500.000 euros le budget est
de 600 millions 610 millions
jusqu'où est la dimension stratégique de
ce dialogue voilà donc avoir un plan qui
soit pluriannuel et dans lequel
l'université
s'engage dans des actions qu'elle pilote
et dans des actions qui viennent de sa
réflexion de la recherche du tissu de
recherche de son environnement de
l'ancrage dans son territoire c'est
finalement
exercé une forme d'autonomie dans de
bonnes conditions ensuite ce qu'il faut
savoir une visibilité pluriannuelle
parce que la temporalité annuelle est
insuffisante pour mettre en oeuvre une
feuille de route stratégique et ensuite
il faut avoir une évaluation qui soit
adaptée à cela c'est à dire
on a défini a priori un objectif
ensemble et on regarde a posteriori si
on a atteint ou pas cet objectif et à ce
moment-là bon c'est probablement le P de
performance mais c'est en tout cas à ce
moment-là que l'on peut convenir de la
suite de la stratégie et de la décation
des moyens donc ça nous semble
intéressant parce que chacune des
universités elle a aujourd'hui son
projet stratégique tout en restant un
opérateur de l'État qu'il s'agisse de
l'accès à l'enseignement supérieur qui
s'agisse du tissu
économique de l'Innovation de la
relation avec les entreprises qui
s'agissent des ambitions de recherche
les universités elles sont dans cette
situation là mais elle voudrait pouvoir
avoir un dialogue constructif qui
permette la mise en oeuvre de de
ces feuilles de route et tout dernier
point sur le sujet parce que les
universités seront très sensibles à ça
ce qu'elle voudront je pense qu'elles
sont capables d'assumer ça ça implique
des différences entre les contrats c'est
qu'une transparence de ce qui est fait
c'est une transparence de ce qui est
fait aujourd'hui il est aussi on n'a pas
de système d'allocation des moyens qui
soient valables comme c'est des vasques
communicants ce que vous vous enlevez
d'un côté vous le remettez à l'autre
voilà c'est c'est compliqué les
universités elles voudraient et on
défend cette position que ceux-ci soit
parfaitement transparent pour qu'on
sache
qui est financé comment et dans quels
objectifs ça me semble assez sain de le
faire de cette manière vous avez évoqué
aussi
alors je prends dans l'ordre
chronologique pardon c'est peut-être
tous ces sujets ne sont pas directement
liés mais vous avez ok le sujet des
bourses et
je crois que monsieur le Président s'il
avait
évoqué bon vous savez qu'on va avoir une
concertation sur la vie étudiante nous
sur les bourses il y a deux volets il y
a un volet national où on pense qu'il
faut revoir
du système et effectivement France
université avait proposé d'aller plus
loin d'aller plus loin en particulier
pour les étudiants qui décohabitent qui
à ce moment-là se retrouvent dans cette
difficulté vous savez les boursiers
il y a une très grande partie des
bourses qui est de très
faible valeur vous prenez alors je veux
peut-être dire
avec beaucoup de précautions mais je
pense qu'on doit avoir entre 700 et
800000 boursiers que là-dedans vous
devez avoir entre 300 et 400 000 qui ont
des bourses qui sont inférieures à 200
euros par exemple bon voilà c'est donc
c'est pas alors quand vous ouvrez ce
dossier vous ouvrez celui de la
fiscalité des parents
vous ouvrez le dossier de la du foyer
fiscal et et là je pense qu'il faut
c'est un coup c'est un coup c'est
indéniable c'est un coup c'est difficile
d'en faire de passer d'un système à
l'autre mais à mon avis on doit avoir
une réflexion il faut être responsable à
ce niveau là comme le font beaucoup de
pays
ensuite il y a une dimension que vous
avez évoquée qui est la dimension locale
et ça pour nous c'est très important
parce que comme je l'ai dit à plusieurs
reprises aujourd'hui les universités
elles ont dans leur projet stratégique
un ancrage territorial qui est qui est
important alors
bien entendu il faut avoir cette
réflexion et nous on pense que la vie
étudiante elle se fait dans dans les
universités il faut qu'elle soit pensée
dans
son territoire et il faut qu'on ait
cette construction qui soit adaptée là
aussi au cas par cas maintenant on a des
sujets qui sont majeurs
qui sont le logement le logement n'est
pas effectivement une donnée qui est
homogène nationale vous et il y a des
régions qui se sont engagées par exemple
dans ma région Aquitaine il y a eu des
actions qui ont été portées par le
président Rousset dans ce sens-là avec
un engagement très fort dans le logement
dans les systèmes de garantie voilà et
on voit bien là qui a une différence
territoriale qu'il faut traiter et
peut-être qu'il faut considérer ça
au-delà de la bourse
étudiante comme l'accompagnement de la
vie étudiante de sa santé du sport du
partage des infrastructures du travail
avec
l'ensemble des des mairies des services
et je pense que c'est par là il me
semble la dimension territoriale et
majeur pour
[Musique]
vie étudiante
je peut-être je poursuis rapidement
en remerciant lors d'Archos sur la LPR
la simplification
même si cette séance est publique ce que
je peux dire que
on est dans un pays qui a beaucoup de
mal avec l'autonomie des universités
parce qu'on a du mal à comprendre qu'un
opérateur de l'État puisse être autonome
donc aujourd'hui quand on décline loi et
on l'a fait avec la LPR on la décline en
vous disant voilà comment vous allez
être autonome donc vous avez des chers
junior donc on va les faire une année
par on va le faire de manière annuelle
et puis vous allez prendre tel type de
profil de professeur non ça c'est pas
l'autonomie et je reviens à vos contrats
d'objectifs et de moyens nous ce qu'on
demandait c'est de dire écoutez on
regarde ça en plus rien annuel vous
laissez faire les universités vous
donnez une dotation sur les chair de
professeurs junior puis vous revenez
dans trois ans et vous évaluez
si on n'a pas bien fait vous les enlever
mais je pense que c'est cette démarche
là donc simplification c'était les CPJ
pardon les chair de professeur junior
l'approche plurianuelle le fait pouvoir
prendre des professeurs de première
classe ou de si on veut attirer d'autres
alinspects
il faut changer un petit peu le système
sur les sur le tout toute la question de
l'indemnitaire il y avait des
restrictions très fortes par exemple
vous pouvez pas cumuler différents types
d'indemnités quand vous allez vous vous
demandez un ancien chercheur
vice-président d'université si vous lui
dites non on peut pas transformer ça en
décharge et il faut que tu continues à
faire 190 € il y arrivera pas vous aurez
pas d'équipe dirigeantes etc etc donc
tout ceci a été quand même très bien
pris en charge par la nouvelle équipe de
Sylvie retaillod et notre nos derniers
échanges avec la la DGRH montre que ça
avance dans des mesures de
simplification qui qui vraiment un petit
peu plus proche de de
l'autonomie des universités
alors vous abordez madame la sénatrice à
un sujet qui est compliqué mais qui est
je pense là aussi ça fait partie des
sujets qu'il faut aborder parce que vous
avez évoqué le fait que madame la
ministre avait dit il faut que on sache
bien quel est le rôle de chacun
France université c'est prononcer
là-dessus nous on pense que dans un pays
comme le nôtre qui a des ambitions
d'être une grande nation scientifique
qui est une démocratie et qui est dans
un environnement extrêmement
concurrentiel il faut avoir des missions
qui sont des missions stratégiques qui
sont liées à l'état vous avez une crise
covid vous aviez du vieillissement vous
avez un problème de
énergétique peut-être que demain il y a
un autre problème qui survient et qui
appartient
au parlementaire
au gouvernement en place
en s'appuyant bien sûr sur les
compétences scientifiques mais ça c'est
de la stratégie ensuite il y a une autre
mission qui est les moyens et la
programmation c'est à dire que on
organise le financement de la recherche
au regard de ses besoins stratégiques et
ensuite vous avez une troisième mission
qui sont les opérateurs ceux qui sont
dans les laboratoires
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on mélange
beaucoup ces trois missions et que on a
d'abord un système très complexe avec
parfois des organismes de recherche on
parle toujours du CNRS monsieur ozulias
évidemment mais c'est vous avez des
dizaines et des dizaines d'organismes de
recherche donc on peut pas dire comme ça
les organismes de recherche la façon
dont vous appréhendez la relation avec
le CNRS qui est multire qui est qui a
beaucoup de disciplines ou
la façon dont vous le faites avec
ria ou l'Inserm ou un fortiori le
[Musique]
l'INRA et qui a fusionné ou l'organisme
qui a aussi intégré Gustave Eiffel sur
les transports
c'est difficile d'avoir une solution
comme ça qui soit unilatérale mais le
rôle de chacun moi je pense que les
universités sont les opérateurs de
recherche elles le font de manière
indissociable avec les organismes il les
chercheurs des organismes
je pense effectivement que les
organismes de recherche s'ils sont déjà
des agences de moyens les peps sont
pilotés par qui sont pilotés par exemple
on peut calculer la somme de l'argent
qui est regardé l'insert ils sont déjà
c'était les recommandations du rapport
de 2007 par une serre en disant qu'il
fallait que la recherche sur le cancer
sur le sida et l'hépatite bien le
financement soit sous le contrôle
d'avisant et de l'Inserm ça ça existe
déjà mais il faut qu'on améliore ça et
alors
si je veux être
totalement comment dire pragmatique sur
cette question je pense que il est
important
que l'État ne mette pas en compétition
les organismes et les universités parce
que c'est ce qui arrive quand même
aujourd'hui un peu vous avez travaillé
sur l'innovation vous l'avez bien vu bon
alors si on passe notre temps à être en
compétition sur la propriété
intellectuelle sur ceci ou sur cela ça
c'est désastreux je pense que le pays ne
veut pas se le permettre et ensuite vous
l'avez évoqué aussi l'ummr la gestion il
y a un problème de gestion aujourd'hui
on a une espèce de répétition des
compétences des fonctions support pour
une université sur moi j'étais président
de Bordeaux vous aviez l'Université de
Bordeaux vous aviez
ma Direction de la recherche la
délégation de l'insert celle du CNRS
celle de l'INRA et un peu plus loin le
CEA
est-ce que on peut
on dirait
c'est coûteux c'est compliqué mais vous
êtes formidable vous faites très bien le
pays scientifique au plan scientifique
le pays explose les plafonds et en plus
sur le plan financier on peut se le
permettre bon pourquoi pas mais c'est
pas vrai
la position de la France décline la
compétition est plus forte et sur le
plan financier on ne peut pas se le
permettre donc je pense qu'il y a un
vrai travail de mutualisation de
hiérarchisation et de clarification en
effet de qui fait quoi et ça ça me
paraît essentiel
enfin pour le quinquennat à venir vous
allez parler également de des alliances
et de l'Europe
alors je
pense ce sont des très bons projets je
pense qu'aujourd'hui la France est en
train de de
alors comment dire cela je veux dire
l'inverse on a souvent on s'est souvent
on a souvent regretté que les
universités françaises soient un petit
peu en retrait par rapport aux
politiques européennes par rapport à
l'investissement c'est beaucoup moins
vrai et avec les alliances
universitaires on est en train de
changer un petit peu la donne
les sujets qu'on a évoqué sur
l'autonomie sur les relations avec les
organismes sur le rôle des étudiants
sont autant de sujets qui nous
permettent d'atteindre les standards
européens alors on peut l'utiliser dans
les deux sens je pense que tous ces
dossiers doivent être
soutenu avancer mais on peut aussi
utiliser les universités européennes
quand vous êtes dans un réseau avec 5 6
7 8 autres universités qui sont
européennes
on peut prendre cet exemple pour se
caler sur les meilleures pratiques la
pression des étudiants est très
importante là dans le domaine des
transitions voilà quand on voit vous
voyez débarquer les étudiants d'une
université irlandaise ils ont
d'université suédoise ils ont sur cet
aspect des choses d'être un vécu une
expérience qui est enrichissante qui
intéresse nos propres étudiants et donc
je crois que la communauté étudiante de
ce point de vue là est très importante
au niveau européen après il y a des
aspects qui sont plus politiques sur au
niveau de l'Europe sur le diplôme
européen quand vous tirez le fil là on
va reparler de
d'autonomie de valeur nationale du
diplôme etc on est pour qu'il y ait un
diplôme de type européen puis après
attention avec les équilibres politiques
parce que le brexit
et la sortie de l'Union européenne sur
la recherche et un facteur de
déséquilibre avant le trio Royaume-Uni
Allemagne France finalement emporter un
certain nombre de décisions aujourd'hui
le couple franco-allemand n'est
peut-être pas
si fort il y a un décalage avec
l'Allemagne qui investit beaucoup plus
que nous dans le domaine de la recherche
voilà et il y a une tentation
du Royaume-Uni de plutôt se tourner vers
les États-Unis et l'Australie aussi dans
le domaine de la recherche et là
l'Union des universités européennes le
ua joue un rôle très important et la
présence des universités dans cette il y
a 800 établissements et joue un rôle
majeur et je pense que c'est une très
bonne chose et puis le tout dernier
point je crois que j'ai peut-être prêt
répondu c'est celui du préciput elle
permet c'est une bonne chose là le
refinancement de la NR la reventilation
de de crédits sur le préciput comment ça
se faire voir celui d'ailleurs aussi sur
la culture scientifique donc ça nous on
trouve que c'est très positif
merci on va continuer les questions
alors cette fois-ci en prenant
l'ensemble des
sénateurs qui souhaitent intervenir je
vous donne dans l'ordre Jean agréé il y
a une chanterelle pierrozilla Max
Brisson Monique de Marco et puis ensuite
il y aura Céline Brulat Annick Billon et
Alexandra borcio Fontain
et aussi Laurence Garnier
et aussi Olivier Pacaud on fera
peut-être plusieurs groupes du coup
allez on commence avec Jean agréés
cher Laurent mes chers collègues
monsieur le Président de France
université moi j'aimerais rebondir sur
OK sur vos propos liminaires parce que
suite aux interventions de Stephen
piénoir et Laure darkos beaucoup de
choses ont été dites sur l'actualité de
la rentrée universitaire vous avez dit
dans votre propos qu'il fallait repenser
les formations d'aujourd'hui pour
envisager l'avenir vous avez dit aussi
que l'apprentissage permettait aux
étudiants de trouver un emploi avec un
taux quatre sacs de 4 à 5 fois plus
importantes que le reste des étudiants
et vous avez dit aussi que à l'avenir
nous allons connaître une augmentation
de 20% des effectifs
à l'université
parallèle de ça je me pose la question
je ne pense pas être le seul peut-être
que tout ce qui est coût du bâtiment
terre coût énergétique pour des
ressources humaines et naturellement
dans un cadre budgétaire limité qu'en
est-il quelle serait vos préconisations
notamment sur la sélection à
l'université qui permettrait
naturellement de réduire l'ensemble de
ses coûts je vous remercie
il y a une chanterelle
merci monsieur le Président comme nom
nombre d'entre vous j'imagine j'ai eu
ces dernières semaines beaucoup de
remontées justement d'étudiants et
d'étudiantes en grande difficulté parce
qu'il n'avait toujours pas de place en
master alors que souvent ils avaient
d'excellents dossiers des situations de
jeunes qui craignaient de perdre le
statut d'étudiant qui s'apprêtait
d'ailleurs à s'inscrire à Pôle Emploi
faute de mieux ou qui voyait leurs
aspirations et leurs projets de carrière
s'effondraient devant leurs yeux et de
même pour ceux qui ont finalement pu
obtenir une place c'était la panique
pour de devoir trouver un logement à
quelques jours de la rentrée d'accomplir
des démarches d'inscription
d'installation alors que les cours ont
déjà commencé alors comme vous le savez
le droit la poursuite des études
garantie aux étudiants titulaires d'une
licence de se voir proposer une
formation de deuxième cycle en lien avec
leur projet professionnel
hors de pu la réforme qui instaure la
sélection et l'entrée justement en
master chaque année des milieux milliers
d'étudiantes et étudiants se retrouvent
sans solution et dans l'incapacité de
poursuivre leurs études ils le vivent
comme une profonde injustice à juste
titre la ministre d'ailleurs nous a
annoncé il y a une quinzaine de jours
une énième plateforme censée régler le
problème pour l'année 2023 2024 la
question de la création de place de
Master supplémentaire pour accueillir
ces étudiants ensemble éluder donc les
questions sont très simples avez-vous
été associées à la démarche de création
de cette plateforme et en quoi
sera-t-elle à même de régler les
problèmes sans création de Master 1
supplémentaire
quels sont les moyens qui vous
permettraient d'être en capacité de
créer des places de Master
supplémentaires est-ce que vous
garantissez que dans cette plateforme ce
seront toujours des commissions
pédagogiques et non des algorithmes qui
analyseront les dossiers puis j'ai un
dernier un dernier point aussi c'est on
a eu une partie du plan du gouvernement
face pour faire face au désert médicaux
et justement il est proposé entre autres
d'envoyer des étudiants en médecine
générale dans les zones sous dotées lors
d'une quatrième année d'études alors
quels sont les retours des universités
concernées par cette disposition aussi
bien sur le fond que sur les modalités
pratiques de mise en oeuvre d'une telle
réforme dans de bonnes conditions se
pose notamment la question des effectifs
de maître de stage universitaire à
mobiliser pour encadrer ses étudiants
étudiantes
le gouvernement a par ailleurs
communiqué sur le lancement d'une
mission commune au ministère de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche et au ministère de la Santé de
la prévention afin de concert se
concerter avec l'ensemble des parties
prenantes de cette réforme avez-vous des
éléments à nous communiquer aujourd'hui
à ce sujet y a-t-il une concertation en
cours je vous remercie
monsieur le Président bonjour monsieur
le Président je voulais poser une
question sur la relation
recherche et université
mais j'aimerais insister surtout du
point de vue des chercheurs vous l'avez
dit notre notre système est relativement
complexe mais c'est pas le seul je
prends justement la liste des prix Nobel
le prix Nobel de médecine a été attribué
à un suéda vente parabos qui a fait
toute sa carrière à l'Institut Max
plante qui est une association sans but
lucratif et qui regroupe 80 instituts
donc c'est encore quelque chose d'autre
et puis moi aussi je tiens à féliciter
Alain Aspect
qui est originaire d'un village de
Gascogne voilà qui a fait ses études au
lycée Bernard Palissy à Agen et je me
pose la question pour savoir si
aujourd'hui un lycéen du lycée Bernard
parlissy d'Agen pourrait accéder aussi
facilement à ce niveau d'excellence je
n'en suis pas si sûr voilà
je rajoute mais c'est un peu politique
que il a très bonne recette de foie gras
une cave exceptionnelle mais une voyelle
aucune allusion à au débat qui anime la
gauche
en revanche c'est
en revanche je trouve que son parcours
est tout à fait exceptionnel de la façon
dont les chercheurs peuvent passer d'une
institution à une autre je rappelle
École Normale Supérieure de Cachan École
Polytechnique un laboratoire du Collège
de France l'Institut d'optique et
directeur de recherche au CNRS et
enseignant donc ça montre bien que il y
a quand même la possibilité de de passer
d'une institution à une autre et de
pouvoir mener un programme dans la
longue durée de ces récentes
déclarations j'en ai retenu une qui me
semble fondamentale il dit j'avais plein
de temps
j'avais plein de temps pour faire une
recherche qui était une recherche
risquée sur laquelle on lui demandait
pas de déposer en permanence des avis
d'être évolué et quand on écoute
aujourd'hui les enseignants chercheurs à
les chercheurs ce qui manque c'est du
temps ils sont complètement
phagocytités par une administration
bureaucratique à côté de laquelle celle
de l'Union soviétique des années 1950
par elle légère
il passe il passe leur temps à s'évaluer
évaluer leur équipe et à évaluer leurs
collègues de bureau ce qui nous demande
aujourd'hui et ce qui demande à la
représentation nationale c'est de leur
faire confiance
ils ont besoin de stabilité et pas
perdre la moitié de leur temps en
démarche administrative vous l'avez dit
la France est sur le reculoir en matière
de recherche on peut pas gaspiller le
temps des chercheurs dans des démarches
sur sur bureaucratique à plusieurs
reprises ici on s'est interroger sur le
sens de l'évaluation notamment telle
qu'elle est menée par le hcrs en
concurrence à celle d'être d'autres
d'autres organismes ça c'est pas du
législatif c'est du règlementaire il y a
vraiment un gros chantier de
simplification du travail des
universités on va les perdre si on fait
pas ça parce que s'il reste en France
c'est pas pour le salaire vous le savez
bien mais c'est pour aussi un
environnement de recherche et donc là
dessus on peut intervenir et il faut le
faire merci monsieur le président Max
Brisson
d'abord rassurer pierre ozoulias
un ancien élève du lycée Louis-Barthou
de Pau peut devenir président de France
université
le président de France université qui a
fait ses études secondaires en Béarn
avant de présider aux destinées de
l'Université de Bordeaux
j'ai deux questions présidentes à vous
poser
la première porte sur le transfert de la
compétence vie étudiante aux régions la
région Île-de-France annoncée le 26
septembre qu'elle était prête à
reprendre la compétence vie étudiante et
que les sollicitait à ce sujet au-delà
et dans le prolongement de réponse à
Stéphane piennois et leur darkos ne
faudrait-il pas au minimum optimiser les
actions des CROUS et des collectivités à
partir de pour la gestion du parc
immobilier et celle de la restauration
et plus largement passez-vous que le
transfert de compétence vie étudiante
vers les régions était une hypothèse de
travail envisageable ma seconde question
vous l'avez évoqué dans votre propos
préliminaire porte sur la réforme
d'information des enseignants par les
inspects qui dépend de des universités
la loi pour une école de la confiance
vous voulez inscrire les masters meph
comme le cursus majeur pour préparer au
métier du professorat et donner aux
universités via les in speed donc un
rôle essentiel et vous l'avez rappelé et
dit votre attachement l'autre votre lors
de votre intervention initiale comment
expliquez-vous alors que 3 ans après le
vote de la loi nous en sommes encore
très loin
de plus le fait que les épreuves des
cocos d'enseignement se déroulent
désormais en Master 2 n'a-t-il pas
contribué à la forte baisse des
candidats des concours est-ce pour
France université un phénomène pour mon
conjoncturel ou structurel n'y
voyez-vous pas aussi la volonté des
étudiants de devenir professeur par la
voie contractuelle contractuelle au
risque d'affaiblir leur formation
professionnelle via les iscpe qui était
au cœur du volet universitaire de la loi
pour une école à confiance
cette loi m'était en effet grâce
permettait et inciter grâce aux MEF à
une professionnalisation plus précoce
voire même au pré recrutement il y a une
formation initiale plus approfondie au
sein des INP ces orientations ne
sont-elles pas de votre point de vue
malmené par les faits
on va rester dans le sud-ouest avec
Monique de Marco
et dans le Bordelais également
moi je me suis le président bon beaucoup
de questions étaient posées
j'en pose une complémentaire voilà donc
en disant la France a perdu 10 000
inscrits en doctorat cette baisse se
témoigne de la gravité de la
problématique liée au troisième cycle
aujourd'hui un cas des doctorants de
bénéficient pas d'un financement dès la
première année dans une enquête que nous
avons reçue de la phase elle nous a
alerté cette
ainsi que le gouvernement sur le manque
de financement et la dégradation de
leurs conditions de vie et de recherche
la page donc fait des propositions afin
d'améliorer ces conditions de recherche
et de vie par exemple
l'accès un contrat doctoral pour 100%
des doctorants il a Reval il a
revalorisation des salaires y compris
des heures d'enseignement de payer en
dessous du SMIC aujourd'hui
il y avait également dans les
propositions un accès efficient au droit
et aux aides sociales parce que 30% de
doctorants n'ont pas donc une
bénéficient pas d'aide sociale par
exemple quelles réponses pouvez-vous
apporter à ces revendications je les
cite pas toutes mais donc celle
d'améliorer la condition donc les
doctorants
Bernard fielle
oui merci monsieur le Président donc
juste point un petit peu complémentaire
sur moi je voudrais revenir sur les CHU
qui ont cette particularité de
rassembler l'enseignement le soin et la
recherche donc vous avez participé aux
coloc à
l'Académie de médecine on sait qu'il y a
eu un rapport de la Cour des comptes moi
j'aimerais avoir un petit peu votre avis
sur sur l'avenir et quel est votre avis
sur sur ce secteur on a parlé donc on a
beaucoup la légalité des chances et
pour pour les étudiants et des gens qui
pouvaient venir de lisser de province
qui peuvent justement préparer de
brillances étudiants moi je dois revenir
sur
d'abord dans les sur les premières
années de médecine et les officines qui
qui accompagnent les élèves madame Vidal
je me souviens quand j'avais posé la
question m'a répondu que l'ouverture du
numerus permettrait de régler le
problème spontanément je crois que cette
année on en a jamais vu autant et on en
avait jamais vu à des coûts aussi
importants il y a quelques universités à
Lyon par exemple ils essayent de monter
justement ces accompagnements au sein de
l'université qui soit gratuites avec une
forme de tutorat moi j'aimerais avoir
votre avis et savoir aussi dernier point
comment vous réagissez cette année on a
l'analyse des entrées dans les grandes
écoles alors on s'y pockagne il y a 9
établissements sur 10 qui sont publics
qui ont fourni les élèves dans des
écoles de commerce c'est cette
établissement privé qui arrive en tête
par rapport aux établissements publics
avec certains des coûts de scolarité qui
sont considérables comment vous
réagissez à ces infos
Julien barjoton pour finir l'expression
de chacun des groupes et puis après je
passerai la parole aux autres sénateurs
bonjour Merci monsieur le Président et
merci monsieur le Président pour votre
intervention j'ai une question sur la
culture scientifique est-ce que vous
pourriez revenir dessus et détailler un
peu on sait qu'un amendement a été voté
pour que l'Agence nationale de la
recherche
consacre 1% de son budget à la partage
de la culture scientifique en France
c'est un amendement à la LPR commence
cet argent est-il utilisé
quels sont les résultats que faire pour
améliorer la connaissance la culture
générale scientifique et le partage de
la connaissance scientifique dans notre
pays on le voit à l'occasion bien sûr
des des personnes qui obtiennent des
prix prestigieux et c'est extrêmement
important mais au-delà il y a parfois on
voit l'impact sur des sujets comme par
exemple la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique et bien un besoin
d'approfondir la culture scientifique
générale dans notre notre pays merci
beaucoup
pendant toutes les questions comme ça ça
vous permettra peut-être de réorganiser
votre vos réponses en fonction Céline
Brulin
je voudrais aussi vous interroger sur
les études de santé et de médecine
puisque la fin du numerus clausus ne
s'est absolument pas traduit par une
augmentation des capacités de formation
en médecine et en santé et que y compris
la réforme des études de santé et
la manière un peu chaotique dont elle a
été gérée pas par les universités je
vous rassure mais qui ont fait ce
qu'elles ont pu à aussi
conduit à ce qu'on
à ce qu'on ne permet pas à un certain
nombre de jeunes qui voulaient devenir
médecin de le faire
et c'est un gros sujet puisque on voit
bien que dans nos territoires les
déserts médicaux avancent de façon très
inquiétante est-ce que France université
a une réflexion et émet je dirais des
exigences comme vous l'avez fait très
clairement par exemple sur les questions
énergétiques vous avez posé exactement
les besoins des universités est-ce qu'il
y a un travail similaire qui est mené
sur ce secteur particulier et est-ce
qu'un travail est conduit avec les
agences régionales de santé parce qu'il
me semble que ça n'est pas ça ne sont
pas les capacités de formation des
universités qui devraient définir
combien on forme de médecins dans tels
et tels endroits mais bien les besoins
des régions en question puisque une des
réponses c'est pas la seule c'est
qu'effectivement on forme là où il y en
a le plus besoin des médecins merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président donc quelques questions
rapides à la fois sur les effectifs vous
avez parlé d'une augmentation de 20% des
effectifs je voudrais savoir si cette
augmentation elle est répartie de
manière de quelle manière sur le
territoire et est-ce que il y a des
universités qui n'ont pas cette
dynamique la deuxième question concerne
la covid la jeunesse a été profondément
malmenée pendant et notamment les les
étudiants en études supérieur pendant
cette crise de la covid avec des
conditions d'apprentissage difficile
alors il y a eu des renoncements des
abandons et les annonces qui sont faites
par rapport à des fermetures
d'universités pour des motifs d'économie
d'énergie feraient qu'on arriverait à
nouveau à des conditions d'apprentissage
difficile des conditions d'isolement qui
mettrai à rue des preuves les étudiants
donc voilà les premières les premiers
éléments sur cette crise de la covid
un autre élément c'est sur le logement
le logement il y a une crise du logement
général mais il y a une crise du
logement véritablement pour les
étudiants on se rend compte quel que
soit les villes étudiantes aujourd'hui
qui a une impossibilité une grande
détresse donc n'est-il pas temps de
proposer un plan d'urgence avec des
solutions adaptées comme il pourrait en
être mis en oeuvre c'est à dire des
modulaires comme nous avons par exemple
dans la cour du Sénat pour héberger
finalement des demandeurs de logement
qui bien souvent se retrouvent dans des
situations extrêmes sans logement ou
avec des logements exorbitants nous
avons reçu hier avec leur Darko c'est un
collectif de scientifiques
concernant la réforme du lycée donc et
notamment la place des filles des filles
dans les dans les filières scientifiques
donc comment avez-vous vécu des formes
du lycée quatre années après quelle
conséquences en tirez-vous et ma
dernière question rejoint les deux
précédentes c'est sur les études de
médecine alors il y a beaucoup de
fausses bonnes idées de des idées qui
semblent miraculeuses lorsqu'on les
expose devant le grand public avez-vous
des propositions qui permettraient enfin
de former des médecins et pas que des
techniciens qui ne connaissent que
l'hôpital public bien souvent et qui ont
une vision de la médecine générale assez
étroite et donc ils sont désintéresse je
vous remercie monsieur le Président
Alexandra borchetont
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de France université après
avoir été frappé durement par la crise
du covid vous le savez aujourd'hui nous
assistons depuis quelques années
maintenant à la crise des masters j'ai
interrogé l'ancienne ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur également
l'actuel aucune réponse concrète ne m'a
été formulée cette réforme à
malheureusement générer un véritable
imboglio avec des conséquences pratiques
délétères comme le démon d'ailleurs les
réseaux sociaux et plus particulièrement
le hashtag étudiant sans master qui ne
cesse d'inonder nos écrans on lit encore
de nombreux témoignages comme celui de
d'Enzo ce matin même qui a postulé à 32
Masters après l'obtention de sa licence
de droit privé et qui n'a pas qui n'a
reçu que des rejets il a néanmoins
persévéré l'année suivante en postulant
à 41 Masters dans pas moins de 30
universités différentes pour encore une
fois voir ces espoirs brisés alors ma
question est la suivante comment
expliquer qu'aucune solution lui était
proposée une situation qui doit tous
nous interpeller
pourquoi vu de votre expertise en tant
qu' ancien président de l'université de
Bordeaux et actuellement de France
université avez-vous concrètement des
solutions après koniser pour lutter
contre ce phénomène des étudiants sans
Master et puis je voudrais vous alerter
sur un autre sujet c'est la formation au
métier du tourisme 10000 postes étaient
toujours vacants au début de l'été en
provençale-côte d'Azur nos
professionnels manquent de bras
l'Institut du tourisme Côte d'Azur
branche de l'université insuffle une
forte dynamique fédérative Inter et
transdisciplinaire auprès des acteurs du
tourisme Nice d'ailleurs le plus ancien
bac + 5 en hôtellerie de France donc je
voulais tout simplement avoir votre avis
sur l'opportunité de développer des
licences professionnelles de développer
l'apprentissage je vous en parler tout à
l'heure qui serait une véritable
opportuné et opportunité pour
l'entreprise pour les étudiants mais
aussi l'université tous les atouts donc
majeurs pour tous les acteurs mais il y
a une problématique l'image du secteur
doit être redorée toutes les universités
d'ailleurs du consortium ont vu cette
année un tassement des inscriptions donc
moins de candidats et pourtant un besoin
croissant je vous remercie Jacques
coopéra
si président monsieur le Président une
interpellation et de questions
l'interpellation vous avez dit dans vos
pollinaires que la France la position de
la France déclinée au niveau de de la
recherche dans en tout cas au niveau de
la recherche moi je voudrais vous
interpeller sur ce qui se passe en
Bourgogne Franche-Comté la commu de
Bourgogne Franche-Comté qui qui a
explosé avec une Université de Bourgogne
qui fête son 300e anniversaire mais
celle de Franche-Comté la plus vieille
sont 6 centièmes en 2023 quelle est la
ligne de crête quel est votre action
comment vous pouvez intervenir pour
faire en sorte que ces universités
puissent travailler ensemble à une
période où on parle beaucoup de
regroupement de mise en synthèse de
travail commun et on le voit déjà qu'il
y a des financements qui risquent de
disparaître vis-à-vis de cela donc c'est
une interpellation même si
je sais tout l'intérêt en tout cas que
vous portez et puis peut-être aussi
l'autonomie des université qui qui est
là qui a été votée en 2007 la deuxième
question c'est la première question donc
suite à cette révélation c'est vous avez
parlé de passoire énergétique et ce qui
a une accélération justement par rapport
à ce qui se passe en ce moment au niveau
énergétique au niveau des fluides et ce
qui est né accélération de des
dévolution des universités qui
pourraient permettre à un moment donné
de passer pas à autre chose mais de
pouvoir régler un ensemble de problèmes
et de circonstances qui n'ont pas la
possibilité en tout cas de pouvoir le
faire et la troisième question c'est le
sport à l'université quelle est sa place
vous êtes présents université de
Bordeaux vous êtes président bien sûr de
France université mais vous êtes
également médecin donc je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui est le sport
santé quelque chose d'important quelle
est sa place et pour terminer enfin la
Fédération des sports universitaire est
une association qui dispose de très très
peu de moyens elle se trouve parfois en
difficulté et ce qui fait que dans
certaines régions elle supprime son
hôtel merci
oui merci monsieur le Président merci
pour cette intervention monsieur le
Président de France université je
voulais vous interroger sur une question
qui fait beaucoup parler en ce moment au
niveau de l'enseignement secondaire qui
est la question de la laïcité
je suis allée regarder sur votre site
internet tout à l'heure pour préparer
votre audition j'ai vu que vous aviez un
certain nombre d'éléments et notamment
je crois un guide de la laïcité qui a
été élaborée par la Conférence des
présidents des universités qui a été mis
à jour plusieurs fois qui me semble-t-il
date de 2015 je voulais avoir le votre
regard sur l'évolution de la situation
aujourd'hui et savoir si à vos yeux vous
disposiez des outils
suffisants y compris législatif pour
faire face à la montée de ce sujet dans
notre société sachant que le cadre
législatif qui s'applique à
l'enseignement supérieur n'est pas le
même que celui qui s'applique à
l'enseignement secondaire merci
Olivier Pacaud merci monsieur le
Président j'ai une question relative à
la notion pardon de liberté académique
l'an dernier il y a eu les polémiques
une grosse polémique autour de la notion
d'islamo-gauchiste qui avait conduit
l'ancienne ministre à vouloir diligenter
via le CNRS une enquête
savait provoqué une réaction assez vive
de France université vous aviez
notamment publié un communiqué de presse
avec des termes très acides ou vous
regrettiez la confusion entre ce qui
relève de cette liberté académique
justement et ce qui relève du
militantisme
alors ma question elle est simple afin
de prévenir de nouvelles polémiques de
temps à autre il y a des petites
résurgences et de s'assurer que
l'institution universitaire soit plus
exigeante sur les atteintes politiques à
l'intégrité scientifique ne faudra-t-il
pas justement clarifier la notion de
liberté académique qui pour leur renvoie
essentiellement à des principes de
tolérance et de respect de la diversité
des opinions autrement dit en fait
est-ce la confusion entre la liberté
académique et la liberté d'expression
qui exposent l'enseignement et la
recherche universitaire à des dérives
idéologiques
vous n'avez pas que des questions
faciles
Robert merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président moi ça va être une question
très facile monsieur le Président est
tout à coup d'abord merci pour vos
propos on a peu parlé de parcoursup la
ministre ne s'est pas dit opposé dans
une audition que nous avons fait au
printemps dernier à l'évolution de
parcoursup pour vous quelle serait ses
évolutions
ça nous permettra parce que c'est vous
savez un sujet que l'on traite dans
cette commission depuis plusieurs années
donc ce sera intéressant d'avoir votre
votre point de vue là dessus merci
beaucoup et enfin Marie Pierre Monnier
merci président
juste rebondir sur mes collègues et
remercier qui ont pour toutes celles et
ceux qui ont parlé de des études de
médecine parce que c'est un vrai sujet
en réalité nous avons fait un rapport
avec la présidente Annick billon qui a
particulièrement ciblé les
problématiques de soins et de dépistage
des cancers féminins en ruralité avec le
manque de spécialistes d'un territoire
de l'eau ma question porte différent je
rejoins mes collègues sur ce sujet ma
question pense sur la queue des
étudiants étrangers donc si le nombre
d'étudiants étudiants étrangers
accueilli en France pour cette rentrée à
Bondy de 8% par rapport à l'an dernier
le répartition n'est pas homogène ainsi
la hausse est bien moindre dans les
universités plus 6% que dans les écoles
de commerce plus
18%, comment expliquer vous ce décalage
est-il lié selon vous à la forte hausse
des frais de scolarité pour les
étudiants étrangers extra-européens qui
a été acteur en 2019
voilà monsieur le Président de
nombreuses questions qui montrent tout
l'intérêt de notre commission vous voyez
à l'enseignement supérieur à la
recherche donc je vais vous redonner la
parole pour les réponses à ces
différents points
alors je vais essayer de d'être le plus
concis possible parce que les questions
sont nombreuses mais de toute façon
je vous en remercie parce que ça montre
effectivement l'intérêt des
sénatrices et des sénateurs pour ces
sujets évidemment très importants
la première question concerne sur le
[Musique]
la question c'est celle de
l'apprentissage de la sélection est-ce
que la sélection
peut amener une réduction des coûts la
réponse est non
les coûts sont essentiellement impactés
beaucoup plus par la recherche que par
l'accueil des étudiants dans une
université vous avez trois secteurs vous
avez l'accueil du public vous avez le
tertiaire vous allez élabos même une
petite université comme enfin
l'université de taille moyenne
multidisciplinaire l'essentiel de sa
charge va au laboratoire ce qui guide la
sélection parce que sélection il y a
c'est pas la question c'est la réussite
des étudiants
c'est la seule chose qui doit guider la
sélection c'est-à-dire
qu'elle est à partir de du jeu de la
volonté de faire des études quelles sont
les chances de réussite pour cet
étudiant là et c'est
de notre point de vue c'est c'est plutôt
cette logique qu'il faut soutenir vous
avez ensuite monsieur le sénateur
chanterelle parler de la place des
masters et des plateformes la plateforme
de des masters bon
je pense qu'il y a alors là aussi je
pense qu'il y a une forme d'hypocrisie à
dire vous avez le droit à la poursuite
des études et vous avez de la sélection
en master donc les masters c'est
sélectif il y a des sélections
je note cependant et je reviendrai vous
avez également posé cette question que
le sujet se pose pour certains masters
parce que quand vous regardez
globalement l'offre des études en Master
le nombre de places en Master et
supérieur au nombre d'étudiants en L3
en revanche ce qu'il s'est passé et
effectivement c'est un sujet qu'il faut
traiter c'est que et d'où la nécessité
de cette plateforme pour laquelle nous
avons été associés c'est qu'il fallait
un avoir un calendrier
pas un calendrier pour chaque université
parce que ce qui se passait c'est que
vous aviez un télescopage des
candidatures puis après vous allez à la
fois des étudiants qui avaient pas de
Master d'un côté et des universités qui
avaient des places vides d'un master
dans l'autre donc l'objectif de cette
plateforme ça n'est absolument pas
d'avoir un algorithme c'est de
fluidifier les voeux de faire de
faciliter le dépôt de candidature pour
qu'il y ait une seule on va dire mouture
de dépôt de candidature et ensuite de
faire en sorte que quand on choisit un
master on libère la place que l'on n'a
pas pris ailleurs
et alors France université a été
associée mais France université est très
attentive à ce que une plateforme ne
viennent pas ce télescoper avec ce que
font toutes les iniversités en termes
d'offres de formation je vous engage à
aller regarder d'ailleurs sur l'offre de
formation comment elles sont publiées
par les établissements et il ne s'agit
certainement pas de faire un deuxième
parcoursup pour le Master nous ne le
souhaitons pas maintenant nous avons des
architectures d'études en Licence Master
Doctorat
il serait de mon point de vue
ne serait pas cohérent de dire que tous
les étudiants de licence doivent aller
en master vous devez avoir une sortie en
licence avec en particulier des
dimensions professionnelles les masters
c'est un niveau de Bac+5 faut donner des
possibilités de rentrer et d'avoir des
validations des acquis de mais on ne
peut pas non plus
balayer la structure des études et
considérer que ce qu'on a beaucoup
critiqué en France quand on rentre à
l'université c'est une formation
tubulaire qui vous amène jusqu'au
doctorat et qui s'arrête en master parce
que sans s'arrête en master donc je
reviendrai pour répondre à votre
question quatrième
médecin année de médecine générale
alors il y a une commission qui a été
mise en place il y a une concertation
moi ce que je voudrais souligner c'est
la chose suivante il faut bien
distinguer ce qui relève de
modifications qui ont très à améliorer
la formation à reconnaître la médecine
générale à la hisser au statut des
autres spécialités ce qui ne s'efface
fait en France il y a eu beaucoup de
bonnes volonté mais on a créé cette
discipline sans qu'elle ait le niveau de
spécialisation d'environnement de
soutien que les autres disciplines parce
que en particulier la France et je
reviendrai sur ces questions là
considère que la formation médicale
c'est l'hôpital bon voilà il faut sortir
de cette équation donc et il faut
distinguer cela de du problème de la
désertification médicale qui est un
autre sujet bien sûr il y a une relation
bien sûr quand vous avez une faculté de
médecine vous avez plus de chance
d'avoir de médecins dans la région mais
aussi
c'est dans ces zones qui sont les plus
désertifiées sur le plan médical que
vous allez facultés de médecine les
moins bien encadrées que vous avez le
moins de mettre de sages potentiel et il
serait pas très sain de laisser penser
que il suffit d'agir sur la formation
pour que ça ait un impact sur la
désertification c'est faux en première
année je sais que vous êtes souvent
sollicité là-dessus mais ça ça n'est pas
vrai c'est pas parce que
malgré tous les efforts de
délocalisation de la PACES donc ça c'est
un sujet là qu'on est en train de voir
avec les les doyens de médecine je pense
que c'est important de si cette
quatrième année doit se faire c'est pour
hisser la médecine générale au rang de
spécialités comme les autres spécialités
et pour que la médecine générale soit un
des pivots de la prise en charge de la
santé de français bon c'est un sujet sur
lequel on peut se revenir
je réponds au sénateur aux olias sur la
recherche on ne veut pas du tout je vous
rassure de démanteler les organisateurs
de recherche on a besoin des organismes
de recherche ils sont excellents ils ont
contribué à la science et contribue
effectivement à la réussite le problème
est un
sujet effectivement
d'optimiser et de d'arriver à avoir un
travail organisme de recherche
université qui
nous permettent de sortir de cette même
situation que vous dénoncez d'ailleurs
alors
vous avez évoqué la question du temps
mais je vous retourne cette même
question effectivement les chercheurs
manquent dedans quand vous regardez les
universités françaises vous les comparez
aux autres universités à l'étranger un
des paramètres qui délai distinguent
c'est l'encadrement en ingénierie et
personnel administratif des chercheurs
et vous avez dit effectivement
professeur aspect il avait du temps il
avait une liberté de pensée sur
que lui donner
son statut d'universitaire avec un
encadrement qui qui lui facilitait la
tâche aujourd'hui ça n'est plus le cas
si nous optimisons notre système avec
les organismes de recherche et en
particulier avec nos compétences en
ingénierie on a un petit peu plus de
chances de libérer du temps pour les
chercheurs et comme je le disais tout à
l'heure avec
notre Président
il faut qu'on recrée les conditions qui
ont permis à ces chercheurs là d'être de
grands scientifiques dans le pays mais
on a un travail à avec les organites de
recherche et vous se faisait allusion au
Max Planck mais le max à l'étranger le
max plan il n'y a pas de du MR il y a
pas une gestion partagée entre le Max
Planck le elmode l'université de Berlin
et je ne sais qui encore il y a une
optimisation du système avec des
allers-retours possibles avec le Max
Planck avec deux relations parfois
difficiles entre Max manqué université
mais effectivement c'est le l'approche
et celui de la de la facilitation
merci monsieur le sénateur Brisson
d'évoquer le lycée Louis Barthou j'y
suis très attaché en effet et je pense
que
c'est un c'est quelque chose d'essentiel
le l'accès à l'enseignement supérieur et
le tissu de formation par les collèges
et les lycées doit permettre aux jeunes
d'accéder à l'enseignement supérieur
vous avez parlé de la vie étudiante
ensuite posé la question
on a beaucoup de respect pour notre
ancienne ministre que mais sur ce point
là je
on n'est pas d'accord parce que on pense
pas qu'il faut que la vie étudiante soit
transférée que ses compétences soient
transférées aux régions les étudiants
ils sont dans les établissements donc si
vous devez transférer quelque chose
transférer le là où sont les étudiants
en revanche ça veut pas dire qu'il n'y a
pas un rôle à jouer alors c'est
peut-être l'expression transfert
en termes de communication si on dit on
transfère les compétences de la vie
étudiante voilà c'est un peu plus
d'impact mais je pense qu'il y a
énormément de chose à faire en
particulier en région
Île-de-France je les ai évoqués et ça
concerne le logement ça concerne moi
dans mon expérience alors madame de
Marco a fait allusion effectivement
aussi à notre collaboration maintenant
l'expérience de président en université
j'ai connu une relation nouvelle avec
les élus de la de la région les élus des
villes avec
une espèce de partage
à la fois d'un plan stratégique
quelqu'un parler de la dévolution vous
pouvez pas faire ça sans le faire main
dans la main avec
la mairie des villes qui vous entourent
les conseillers et je pense que cette
démarche en revanche elle est très
importante sans pour autant conférer
comme si la vie étudiante une manière
mécanique on dit bah tiens on confie ça
aux régions où on confie ça au CROUS
non je pense que la vie étudiante est un
ensemble c'est la vie en plus et chacun
doit y lire sa part
vous avez parlé aussi de la formation
des enseignants pourquoi en étant là
parce que les lois n'ont pas été
mises en place que mon l'attendait et
qu'en particulier de la
professionnalisation et pour des raisons
financières
les stages que devraient avoir les
étudiants ne sont pas au rendez-vous il
y a eu un rapport de
Bernard Saint-Girons et monicronzo sur
la question parce que il faut
professionnaliser les professeurs des
écoles comme on le fait pour les
médecins ou pour d'autres métiers et que
ceci n'a pas été organisé de de cette
façon là et je pense que
au fur et à mesure le France université
était le seul acteur à une finie a
continué à appuyer la réforme parce que
tout le monde se défausser et il faut
aujourd'hui je pense que l'idée d'avoir
des parcours labellisés dès la première
année pour
saisir l'opportunité des vocations parce
qu'il y a des vocations dans la
formation après il y a c'est très inégal
dans le territoire évidemment
Versailles c'est pas l'académie de
Bordeaux et vous n'avez pas les mêmes
listes d'attentes et vous n'avez pas les
mêmes mais je pense qu'il faut on n'a
pas besoin d'une nouvelle réforme ça
serait de mon point de vue délétère mais
en revanche il faut qu'on fasse des
projets adaptés dès la L1 articuler avec
et poser des questions sur la science
dont je reviendrai une un rôle majeur de
l'école
et effectivement de remettre la science
au cœur de l'éducation des jeunes et ça
c'est essentiel où vous voulez vous le
faire en dehors de l'université donc ça
ce sont quelque chose c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut qu'il faut faire
absolument et aussi corriger ces
orientations un problème de la mixité le
problème des vocations des des filles
dans le domaine des mathématiques la
vocation aussi dans certains parcours de
situation tout ceci se passe pour une
grande partie quand même à l'école il
faut que nous puissions avancer dans ce
domaine là Madame De Marco madame
masénatrice effectivement mais je suis
d'accord avec vous sur le doctorat oui
il faut plus le valoriser pour plus le
financer
alors c'était prévu dans la LTR mais
c'est pas suffisant il faut qu'on
continue voilà on n'est pas un pays de
doctorat on devrait être un pays de
doctorat on a une très bonne université
d'organismes d'ailleurs je signale sur
organisme qui te serait dommage que les
organismes
ne fassent que de la recherche ils
participent aussi à la formation vous
pouvez pas investir dans des organismes
qui sont comme dit le CNRS le vaisseau
amiral de la science en France et que
ceci ne soient pas transféré dans la
formation donc on a besoin de ça et on a
besoin d'avoir des doctorats qui soient
mieux Réunion on a des compétitions
européennes vous savez les cales entre
les calendriers et le niveau de
financement les Français des fois ils
vont aller chercher des
doctorat ailleurs des pièges qui et à ce
niveau je me permets de vous alerter
je ne sais pas
nous on considère que vous allez les
docteurs il y a les bourses il y a les
chiffres il y avait un dispositif qui
s'appelle les COFRAS pour qu'on puisse
faire le doctorat dans la fonction
publique la Cour des comptes etc voilà
j'ai entendu dire que du côté de Bercy
on passait de 100 à 10 ou je ne sais pas
il y avait un projet de financement de
bourse de doctorat en lien avec
l'Institut avec l'inespe de service
public on en avait parlé avec
le brigonien il serait dramatique que à
peine démarre la la trajectoire du
docteur pour la fonction publique les
bourses disparaissent
alors je continue vous avez pris des
notes pardon donc
monsieur le sénateur Keller je crois
ensuite évoquer la question du CHU
je pourrais consacrer une séance entière
à la question du CHU
pardon monsieur le sénateur fialet
excusez-moi j'ai écorché votre nom
ben voilà
je pardon de cette confusion c'est voilà
monsieur le sénateur alors
trois questions à venir du CHU vous me
dites quel est votre sentiment
mon sentiment il est pas bon parce que
je pense que le CHU va dans le mur
et que le
U du CHU est en train peu à peu de ces
détériorer parce qu'on est avec un
système hospitalier qui est en grande
tension et donc il a été construit en
1958 avec l'idée que la triple mission
pouvait permettre c'est vrai là ça a été
une grande réussite française pouvait
permettre de faire la formation en
s'appuyant à la fois
sur la clinique et puis sur une
recherche clinique qui aujourd'hui a
fondamentalement changé et aujourd'hui
il est primordial de repenser d'abord le
modèle économique du CHU un modèle qui
pense financer la recherche et la
formation sur la tarification à l'acte
en essayant de faire des marges sur un
système qui est difficile
c'est presque un congru donc ça n'est
pas possible
ensuite les hospitalots universitaires
sont noyés sur des tâches
cliniques qui les accomplissent avec
beaucoup de mérites beaucoup de
vocations encore que vous avez de 50 à
60 professeurs de médecine qui
démissionnent chaque année enfin
50 à 60 depuis 2018 donc ça fait quand
même un nombre de démissions chaque
année qui est inquiétant parce qu'on a
une perte d'attractivité
et ensuite je pense qu'il faut ouvrir
l'enseignement de la médecine et des
professions de santé la santé c'est pas
que la médecine il faut l'ouvrir à la
ville à la société on a évoqué la
médecine générale il faut qu'il y ait
une dimension de santé publique qu'on
n'est pas et puis il faut l'ouvrir sur
le plan disciplinaire l'avenir une
partie de l'avenir de la médecine c'est
du numérique c'est des dispositifs c'est
de la physique c'est pas forcément que
de la médecine et donc on est
effectivement inquiet et on pense qu'il
faudrait qu'il y ait une réforme des
hôpitaux universitaires avec des
périmètres qui soient peut-être plus
ciblées sur ceux qui peuvent ceux qui
font de la recherche et de l'innovation
parce qu'il y a des problèmes de
gouvernance aussi parce que là le carcan
administratif que vous avez évoqué et
majeur et délétère mais on a confié la
loi HPST la décider à ce moment-là donc
je crois que c'est c'est un sujet de
préoccupation même préoccupation pour
les organismes privés alors quand
j'étais président l'Université de
Bordeaux je mené une lutte qui
bon
les résultats étaient
à nos yeux assez
favorable parce que
à Bordeaux lorsqu'on réussissait la
première année de médecine c'est parce
qu'on avait été accompagné par le
tutorat pour la majorité des étudiants
un tutorat gratuit et basé sur enfin qui
n'a rien à voir avec les systèmes des
officines privées et nous sommes
préoccupés par effectivement la le
la multiplication de ces officines
privées alors on peut être d'accord pas
d'accord le problème c'est la qualité de
l'enseignement qui est donné et est-ce
que ça améliore les chances de réussite
des étudiants et ça ça c'est un problème
majeur qu'il faudrait regarder
oui nous constatons qu'il y a de plus en
plus d'orientation vers les
établissements privés c'est aussi un
sujet de préoccupation surtout quand on
entend qu'il devrait être aussi soutenu
par l'État
il faut qu'on clarifie un certain nombre
de choses dans le rôle de les
établissements privés en France et dans
nos régions
vous avez
[Musique]
vous avez ensuite je crois
évoquer les questions de
culture
scientifique
et je crois que c'est monsieur
barjoton qui a évoqué ce sujet alors
je pense qu'on a avancé je pense que le
1% de la NR est une excellente chose je
pense aussi que ce qui a été fait sous
le gouvernement précédent qui consistait
à labelliser des établissements
sciences pareil pour la société avec des
vices présidents qui sont spécifiquement
en charge de la politique de relation
entre la science et la société
a bien fonctionné
on est à France université on a un
groupe de travail alors
j'ose dire que
celle qui animait ça était Sylvie
retaillod qui dirigeait à la commission
recherche avec Virginie Dupont donc je
pense qu'elle aura à coeur de poursuivre
cette action de relation entre la
science et la société mais je au delà
des labels de l'action des universités
des et des structures spécifiques
j'attire quand même l'attention sur
l'école la culture scientifique à
l'école la formation des formateurs des
choses très positives qui ont été faites
par exemple avec la main à la pâte
l'Académie des Sciences sur les Maisons
des Sciences ça ce sont les choses qui
marchent très bien la Fête de la Science
et ces actions ciblées dans les écoles
dans les collèges avec ces vocations
scientifiques aujourd'hui se perdent en
particulier avec cette ce problème de
mixité aussi je pense qu'on voilà il
faut que la science soit à nouveau au
cœur de la formation assez tôt après il
faut que l'université joue un rôle et je
pense que le France université est très
attentive à ça et on va faire un peu le
bilan de ces actions de ces labels avec
des financements qui sont venus aussi en
complément d'autres financements parce
qu'il y a eu des des projets aussi des
appels à projets sur sur cette question
de les actions de
envers la diffusion de la science auprès
des citoyens
madame
la sénatrice brûle
vous posez la question effectivement des
études de médecine des déserts médicaux
bon j'ai répondu en partie mais
là aussi
le fond de la réforme c'était
cet objectif de diversifier de mettre
fin au gâchis humain de la passerelle de
quelqu'un de l'a évoqué également aussi
de d'avoir des profils d'étudiants qui
finalement
se retrouvent enfin
en cohérence avec le métier qui veulent
faire et donc c'était de diversifier
ces études là de d'inclure aussi des
parcours de ne pas pénaliser ceux qui
venaient de parcours dans d'autres
disciplines en sciences humaines et
sociales
endroits dans des parcours scientifiques
il y a beaucoup de pays où vous avez une
forme de tronc commun qui amène ensuite
à des études médicales c'était
l'objectif de
la réforme alors nous on a soutenu cette
réforme en disant deux choses
1 ça sera pas en un an c'est très
compliqué il va falloir deux trois ans
pour pouvoir le faire ne serait-ce que
parce que vous avez un chevauchement
avec les systèmes anciens pendant un an
qui ont été très perturbants très
perturbant
et ensuite parce que vous avez toujours
le retour d'expérience avec un comité de
suivi auquel on participe par exemple le
fait d'avoir des universités vous savez
qui font des accès uniquement par les
licences ou autres que santé mais il
faut un corpus commun de santé que vous
ne pouvez pas galvauder et là c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas encore
complètement rentré dans les usages vous
pouvez pas faire une licence de droit
qui est qui est très exigeante et en
plus faire une formation avec le on va
dire le socle de connaissance nécessaire
à poursuivre des études de médecine il
faut adapter ces formations là alors moi
je crois que c'est quelque chose qui est
en train
de se faire je pense qu'il faut faire
attention à la diversification ensuite
des carrières et des métiers vous savez
on a ce sujet avec la pharmacie ou les
étudiants ne vont pas vers la pharmacie
dans quelle préoccupation des
pharmaciens de voir ce qui est justifié
parce qu'aujourd'hui malgré tout on a
une vision un petit peu monolithique de
médecine je veux être médecin et
peut-être aussi qu'on a fait croire que
la fin du numérique clausus c'est que
tout le monde pouvait aller en médecine
ça ça c'est une ânerie dans tous les
pays du monde c'est très compliqué c'est
difficile ça restera difficile et ça
restera restreint et oui il y aura
toujours une forme de sélection pour
être médecin comme dans d'autres
formations
et je pense qu'il faut pas laisser
penser que modifier le ça n'a rien à
voir avec la question d'adapter le
numérique clausus avec
la région avec la question des déserts
médicaux quel est le rôle des
universités des doyens on travaille très
bien avec les doyen en médecine comment
on fait pour adapter effectivement
cela je pense qu'il est très important
que dans les études les étudiants soient
immergés dans des environnements dans
lesquels il se projette si vous formez
un étudiant qui est tout le temps à
l'hôpital et que il voit le service de
cardiologie de réanimation qui le
structure il y a peu de chances
qu'ensuite
ils veulent devenir médecin de campagne
moi dans ma génération justement à Louis
Barthou on voulait revenir
du côté de Pau parce que l'objectif de
mes collègues en première année de
médecine c'était d'être médecin à
espoeil à Soumoulou et c'est là qu'on se
projetait et finalement après un cursus
de médecine beaucoup d'entre nous
revenaient dans leur contrée d'origine
aujourd'hui on le voit beaucoup moins
avec en plus effectivement des exigences
sociales qui sont tout à fait légitimes
et qu'on ne doit pas isoler à la
médecine parce que la désertification si
c'est la déversification médicale seule
on peut le comprendre et c'est un sujet
mais si cette diversification médicale
elle s'accompagne d'une désertification
de l'éducation nationale des services
du transport
à ce moment là effectivement comment
vous voulez vous
être attractif pour ces générations il y
a un travail spécifique à faire et ça
revient à ma réflexion sur la quatrième
année de médecine c'est pas uniquement
en transformant la formation qu'on va y
arriver oui il faut travailler avec les
ARS voilà condition que les ARS
oui et puis comprennent effectivement
soit dans cette dans cette état d'esprit
mais
voilà le problème c'est que c'est un
problème national et si vous dites si
vous adressez à une zone désertifiée et
où il y a déjà moins de moyens et moins
d'encadrement et une faculté de médecine
avec moins de professeurs
il faut traiter ça au niveau national
monsieur non madame la sénatrice billon
vous m'avez interrogé sur l'augmentation
de des étudiants leur répartition non
elle n'est pas uniforme je peux pas vous
donner de chiffres mais c'est sûr que
cette augmentation n'est pas uniforme et
que il y a des universités qui peuvent
accepter peut-être plus d'étudiants mais
j'attire votre attention sur le fait et
ça c'est un sujet qui revient
régulièrement c'est que
l'attention elle existe sur certaines
filières pas surtout
les étudiants ils veulent aller en santé
en droit en psycho on STAPS ces filières
sont en tension elles sont moins en
tension dans certaines universités que
dans d'autres mais si vous voulez faire
des études en maths physique en
mathématiques
vous pouvez aller partout en France et
très bien le faire donc cette hétérogène
effectivement dans dans le pays je suis
d'accord avec vous sur les conclusions
du covid on veut pas du tout revenir
vers ça c'est pas du tout la position de
France université on en a tiré les
leçons la formation à distance au début
on a pensé que oui ça nous a surtout
montré que la présence était essentielle
ça a modulé aussi la façon d'enseigner
et il y a beaucoup de transformation
pédagogiques grâce au covid mais pas
forcément en dématérialisant les choses
est-ce qu'il faudrait un plan le
logement étudiant oui je le pense en
accord avec les régions
la
démolition du patrimoine n'est pas la
seule solution
j'ai répondu à la question sur les
études de médecine sur les études de
au lycée qu'elle a été l'impact c'est
peut-être en encore un peu tôt là on le
voit encore vous avez interrogé sur
parcoursup il faut qu'on puisse intégrer
ce qui n'a pas été fait jusqu'à présent
le le
les spécialités le suivi de ses
spécialités et puis je pense que
l'évolution doit être celle d'une
certaine transparence tout le monde
demande à ce qui est une transparence on
peut très bien comprendre que si vous
avez
4000 étudiants pour
180 places en psycho on peut pas prendre
tout le monde en revanche tout le monde
a le droit de savoir sur quelle base et
sur quels critères on choisit les
étudiants et ça ça ce qui me paraît le
plus important
madame
[Musique]
borchio je crois que vous avez évoqué la
crise des masters
alors si je peux me permettre je pense
que vous avez donné la réponse dans
votre deuxième question
parce que
si parce que la crise des masters c'est
que les étudiants n'ont pas de place
pour aller en master mais parce que les
étudiants veulent tous le même master
il y a plus de place en master quand
licence donc vous avez évoqué le droit
alors 40 demandes 52 demandes
effectivement si vous avez par exemple
un master en droit international vous
allez pas ouvrir les effectifs en master
en droit international jusqu'à saturer
les vœux des étudiants
et je dis que c'est en lien avec votre
deuxième question pourquoi parce que
dans votre question deuxième question ce
qui est une excellente idée on avait
essayé de le faire à Bordeaux vous vous
prescrivez un besoin qui n'est pas un
vœu d'étudiant c'est le besoin
économique c'est dit mais dites donc
pourquoi vous faites pas plus de
formation en une autorismes en pardon
c'est la déformation bordelaise en
tourisme mais pourquoi vous faites pas
plus mais vous avez raison mais comment
vous mettez vous faites correspondre les
voeux des étudiants aux besoins de la
société aux besoins de l'économie et
puis votre demande c'est une demande de
sortie de licence professionnelle à Bac
+3 pas de créer de nouvelles places en
master alors je pense que une grande
partie du problème en master était liée
à la façon de le faire mais là aussi moi
je prêche pour être
le plus
transparent possible
les masters
c'est sélectif et dans certains masters
sont très sélectifs et on ne peut pas
prendre toutes les candidatures qui
viennent de la licence même si le
principe de
pouvoir poursuivre les études et
vertueux et pourraient s'imaginer aussi
à se faire à d'autres périodes de cursus
monsieur gros Perrin oui vous
interpellez sur la commune Franche-Comté
travaille entre deux universités c'est
vrai
des choses qui nous chagrinent qui
existent qui ont existé parfois dans la
construction des sites donc on a une
relation avec les deux présidents qui
aujourd'hui
collaborent je pense que je pense qu'il
faut aussi pouvoir s'appuyer ensemble
sur l'évaluation parce que dans des
moments comme ça où vous avez toujours
des
positions d'un établissement par rapport
à l'autre sur un même territoire je
pense qu'à un moment donné il faut
pouvoir évaluer les choses objectivement
parce que souvent on se revanche sur des
postures des postures parfois politiques
ou régionales ou de défense de tel ou
tel acteur et je pense qu'à un moment
donné il faut évaluer les choses et le
faire de la manière la plus âgée
objective possible vous avez posé aussi
la question du parcours énergétique la
dévolution attention la dévolution si
vous demandez à l'université qui a 500
000 m² ou 800000 mètres carrés et qui a
des passoires énergétiques de prendre la
dévolution d'une façon pour l'état de se
défausser sur l'établissement pour voilà
vous savez les premières dévolutions se
sont accompagnées de compensation
financière voilà donc moi je pense qu'il
faut avoir bon je pense qu'il y a trop
de mètres carrés je pense qu'il faut
optimiser et que aujourd'hui on a
l'opportunité dans ce contexte de
sobriété énergétique d'avoir des
véritables plans même sans dévolution
qui nous permettent d'avoir des courbes
vertueuses et puis vous avez évoqué
aussi la question du sport sur laquelle
on a mis en place un groupe de travail
avec Stéphane braconnier rencontrer la
ministre c'est très important le sport à
l'université c'est trois choses c'est le
sport dans les études avec la
reconnaissance d'unités qui sont dans le
sport c'est le sport en pratique libre
et c'est le sport
et c'est le sport de compétition
universitaire vous savez que nos
athlètes alors là il y a eu beaucoup de
choses parce que évidemment on a les
Jeux olympiques mais pas suffisamment il
y a pas de raison que les on ne il faut
accompagner les athlètes de haut niveau
dans l'université française vous avez
beaucoup de médaillés aux Olympiades qui
sont l'équivalent des Jeux Olympiques
pour les universités se retrouveraient
ensuite des champions
olympiques français donc je pense que
les universités en prennent conscience
mais c'est vrai que c'est très inégal et
que sur les infrastructures quelques
universités partagent une très grande
majorité des équipements de sport de
sport du pays et là aussi moi je vois
une approche régionale qui pourrait être
vertueuse quand vous avez
si avec Madame de Marcon on se promène
sur la communauté de bordelaise vous
allez voir que toutes les villes elles
ont des gymnases des stades que
l'université en a que le CREPS en a il
faut qu'on ait une action de
mutualisation là-dessus pour pour le
sport
madame la sénatrice Garnier sur les
questions de laïcité bon elles sont au
cœur effectivement de nos réflexions
vous a souligné le guide que nous avons
fait vous avez raison de dire que nous
n'avons pas de nouvelles édition en 2000
depuis 2015 ça sera l'automne à
l'automne là on a le guide de la laïcité
alors vous avez rappelé que les
règlements n'étaient pas le même dans le
secondaire et dans le et dans le dans le
supérieur bon aujourd'hui je pense qu'il
faut accompagner les établissements qui
sont peu nombreux il faut pas ignorer ce
problème faut pas balayer ça d'un revers
de main non mais en revanche il faut
aussi admettre que ces problèmes ne se
posent que dans quelques établissements
qui sont très peu nombreux mais sur
lesquels à ce moment-là il faut
accompagner les présidents et nous ce
que l'on fait on fait des formations et
on aide dans cet accompagnement en
particulier bon s'appuyant sur le guide
aussi en s'appuyant sur des échanges des
formations
je vais je termine alors Monsieur
sénateur Paco vous avez parlé de
l'islamo gauchisme parce que ce oui le
président disait pas que des questions
faciles alors je pense que la polémique
de l'islamo gauchisme est une mauvaise
polémique on a réagi et si on devait
réécrire le communiqué on leur a écrit
de la même façon
en revanche je vous rejoins sur la
notion de liberté académique que nous on
souhaitait inscrire
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs s'il
y en a l'opportunité dans la
Constitution à un moment donné parce que
ça existe la constitution de certains
pays
voilà
écrivons le
et
écrivons-le écrivons-le l'université
elle est elle est le reflet de ce qui se
passe dans le pays ces questions-là sont
au cœur de la recherche de la discussion
si vous allez aujourd'hui dans les
universités françaises on va parler de
l'Iran
et en parler des femmes qui déchirent
leur voix c'est ça l'actualité aussi
mais basons nous sur des principes qui
sont des principes saint celui de la
liberté académique il est très important
participer il y a peu de temps un coloc
à Sciences Po avec Mathias viecherin qui
organise ça sur maintenant les
indicateurs de liberté académique
pour les amoureux des rankings quand
vous regardez la place des universités
anglo-saxonnes vous avez du souci à vous
faire ils sont pas dans le top 10 ils
sont plutôt dans le top 30 40 voilà et
je pense que la France aurait intérêt
effectivement à défendre et à en faire
un faire de lance nous n'avons pas à
rougir que de nos différentes actions
parcoursup j'en ai parlé Orient madame
sénateur Robert
je pense que l'évolution
je vais très vite
merci à Chris Robert
non je pense qu'il faut que ça il faut
aller plus loin
il faut être transparent il faut que
l'on faut que ceux qui utilisent
parcoursup sache comment les choix sont
faits quels sont les choix des équipes
pédagogiques faut faire un effort en
matière d'orientation pour moi le
problème de parcoursup ne peut pas se
suffire à parcoursup on a un problème
d'orientation et on a un problème
d'orientation dans le secondaire
si je peux vous me permettre une petite
anecdote puisque monsieur Brisson a dit
que j'étais à Louis Barthou moi Louis
Barthou en première mes parents étaient
convoqués en disant à nos manuel en
médecine c'est pas possible là il fera
jamais médecine
voilà un autorise
bon alors ça a changé ça a changé
l'investissement des professeurs de
lycée là on le voit c'est c'est
extrêmement vertueux mais on est loin
encore de ce qu'on peut faire en matière
d'orientation et quand vous retrouvez
avec ces sujets d'orientation
à l'université est-ce qu'on peut pas
dire qu'il n'est pas déjà un peu trop
tard
est-ce que est-ce que c'est pas un peu
trop tard donc moi parcoursup je ne
dissocierai pas de la problématique de
l'orientation et je termine en nous
répondant à madame la sénatrice Monnier
sur les études de médecine je crois que
j'ai répondu sur l'accueil des étrangers
les droits différenciés vous savez la
plupart des universités elles ont
elles ont voté des comment dit-on
des exonérations parce que on en a
beaucoup d'étudiants qui viennent de
pays
en particulier d'Afrique subsaharienne
ou de pays en voie du développement de
développement qui ne peuvent absolument
pas payer ses droits et donc la
génération de ces droits et très
modeste et je pense qu'elle n'explique
pas la différence avec
l'accueil dans les écoles moi je pense
que ce qui explique cette différence
c'est que quand vous avez des étudiants
étrangers dans une université vous avez
deux façons de et quand on calcule les
étudiants étrangers le nombre
d'étudiants étrangers dans l'université
il y a deux aspects il y a je vais dans
une université Campus France sans fêlés
vous avez des ambassades dans les pays
et on va faire ses études en France
sur le tout-venant là c'est un problème
d'attractivité du pays
quelles conditions on donne aux
étrangers qui viennent comment on les
accueille comment on les loge
on peut en parler de ça
et ça ça conditionne vraiment la
tractivité de la France
en matière d'étudiants à l'étranger
après il y a un deuxième type de
mobilité c'est l'étudiant qui dit moi je
vais venir à telle formation je vais une
licence je suis dans un pays étranger et
je vais faire mon master ou le faire ma
thèse dans tel université ou parfois je
vais faire une licence ou un master en
partage parce qu'il y a un parcours
international ça ça ressemble beaucoup
plus à ce que font les écoles de
commerce ou ce que font les écoles
d'ingénieurs vous savez une partie une
mobilité obligatoire à l'étranger une
partie du cursus mais ça ça demande
beaucoup de travail et évidemment en
termes de nombre ça n'a pas du tout le
même impact
sur des chiffres au niveau national mais
c'est vers ça qu'il faut aller et je
pense que c'est très important même si
aujourd'hui évidemment le spectre de
l'énergie va avoir un impact sur la
mobilité voilà je vous remercie merci
monsieur le Président je crois que nous
avons tous apprécié la précision de vos
réponses
[Applaudissements]
et mes collègues viennent de se
manifester pour vous exprimer leur
remerciement la précision de vos
réponses sensibles et la tension que
vous avez porté à chacun des sujets que
nous avons abordé vous avez vu à travers
la diversité des thèmes que notre
commission est très attentive
aux universités bien sûr et je crois que
c'était important pour cette première
rencontre qu'on balaye de manière très
large les différents sujets et on a noté
aussi ce que vous nous avez pu nous dire
pour le projet de loi de finance je vous
rappelle que nos auditionnerons dans
quelques jours la ministre plus
spécifiquement là-dessus donc votre
audition de ce matin était importante
aussi sur cet aspect là en perspective
de cette audition merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président merci à vous merci
à tous